I thank you for
everybody coming here this is-
the first select committee on
homelessness for LA county that
were hosting- here in Los
Angeles- we wanted to do it
here in Skid Row not just
because I represent the
district are because we wanted
to we wanted to make the point
about how urgent this issue is
not the- remedy would agree. On
it is the number one issue on
people's minds when you walk
out of the street. It is the
number one issue on on our
conscience and in the
legislature we tried over the
years to address this issue.
Now we are very clear from the
beginning that this is not
gonna be an exercise in and
finger pointing but I think
it's fair to say that. At this
point in time- that some of the
decade old policies that we
have put in place are no
longer- affected were working-
today. And I think it's fair to
say that if we continue down
that path. We're going to
continue to see- the results
that we just currently seem
like an explosion homelessness-
twelve in and 16% respectively
from city and county I think we
have to accept that fact. On in
part of what we're doing today.
Is beginning larger ever say
about. About coordination-
resources the best ideas what
works what doesn't work. On an
understanding that that today's
a new day so. The things that
we would have not talked about
in the past. As acceptable the
public policy. Except in today
because- we can no longer on.
We can longer avoid. The issue
homelessness and we can no
longer- be complacent about.
Not have that sort of sense of
urgency and all. All on echo
what my colleague could set. A
few weeks ago- Bob Hertzberg at
a press conference I center Bob
Hertzberg and he said. When he
went up to speak he said it. I
think you said three words he
said urgency urgency urgency
and then some more urgency. And
then walked up I think the
point that we were trying to
make at that time. What was
that we have to address it at
this point in time. And we want
to break the old paradigms we
want to take a look at new ways
of doing it. And we've good.
Earth but we've got to do a
little bit better could. I we
had we've had great. Success
working with the city we've had
great success working with the
county- philanthropic groups
business. Groups but we've got
to do it a little bit. A little
bit differently I would say-
let me share in an and I
promise I will be as long down
the line a by this issue. One
of the reasons why this issue
so important what struck me.
And I've said this a couple
times. When I first got elected
to the legislature. I was happy
go lucky as anybody could ever
be. You get elected you get a
call from the speak your member
those days right. And you get a
call from speaker everybody's
got that call and said Hey come
on up we want to discuss which
want to serve on. Out happy.
And on my way to the airport
that one particular day it just
so happened. That he had
stopped at a corner and was
right good right. Nice to look
right down the street on in the
arts district so. You could see
homelessness when you walked
outside of a house. The what
was unique about this time it
was a lot there was a lady. And
a small baby. And the baby was
in a stroller. And people tell
us that there are no kids on
the street there are kids on
the street. We'll see them. And
the baby was trying to grab the
mom's attention. And you could
imagine and now we've all seen
this picture or this image. And
the longer the baby tried to
grab the mother's attention it
seemed to me that that that
that light had gone forever.
And all I could remember. And
it haunts me to this date of
what could happen of that
child. And one of those tents.
What could have child is
somebody given that person help.
And what more could we have
done. And it's at that sort of
sense of urgency. But I want to
start this hearing. And we'll
get we'll have time for an
overview but what I really want
to do right now it is handed
over my colleagues and then.
Say one word to spend she in
which I've got his political
many got shown giving you don't
notable que esta. Es de temas
of them a must import on the
guest on will be under a kia
and California handicap even
ask I guess to some but I seem
to be the end. You look at some
of that bundle that said I key.
Is that that equity not most
roles. As what was will keep
them at hold in also lamented
did out of the network problem
up it'll cam was más this will
doubles back I handle be about.
I. Over my colleagues in no
particular order if you're
comfortable as I. Just jump on
in and say a couple of opening
words and I know that we have
a- a center Mitchell back their
summer. She walked in. I'm
sorry I apologize- in any and-
if you. Would introduce
yourself and it make opening
comments we can start that for.
We'll start with the wisest
. Of
.
Nobody still can't see on.
Thank you madam budget year.
Nobody nobody should sleep on
the streets in Los Angeles
period and the point period and
I said last time and I'll say
it again urgency urgency
urgency people don't care with
your city government state
government county government
their pay in taxes they want
the problem solved we need to
do what we need to do it now
urgency urgency urgency that's
why I'm here- taking the time-
supposed to be in Sacramento
but when the charm. Me and ask
me told me to. Bring aye my
schedule to be. Because. Board
center but also it is hard and
I'm telling you if we don't
deliver for the folks they got
every right to be even matter
they currently are. Good
morning thank you Mister
chairman for invited me I want
to thank one guard on the
service providers who will be
educated us today here to
listen to your partners in
taking action. And out
assemblymember Reggie Jones
Sawyer I too am. Happy to be
here you know. In the nineteen
ninety five ninety six I was a
middle aged system W. mayor
which is C. of Los Angeles when
we're talking about Lhasa. And
Natalie Kerr creating a bit
making it better. And the
solutions I don't think it
changed nineteen ninety five-
many of it may just have been
our inability to implement a
lot of things and so I'm I'm
here to listen to the experts.
On how not not only just how we
implement them but how quickly.
We can get this done because I
don't think we need to we have
to problem anymore we need to
just have a focus like a laser
discussion order on solutions
and how we can quickly
implement them. Because my
colleagues that the or me the
public. Every form I go to in
my district when I. Give people
opportunities- we what they
want me to legislate. They tell
me what can the state do. To
make sure that. We can do
something for the people were
living. Outside on the street.
First of all of the thank you
very much my name is Mike
Gipson I represent the sixty
four to so many years ago I
think I'm chairman Santiago. My
colleagues- and also wine
garden for all of you being
here- one I want to find out
solutions and work and partner
with- each and everyone of you
I want to commend the great
strong leadership of our
chairman- who's a brought us
all together. This is a
personal issue for me- as we
rated thanksgiving- I was
looking for my god so. That's
nine years he's on crystal meth
and he's homeless. This year I
said the state assembly member.
Who's sitting up here has
someone in the family it is
homeless on the streets due to
crystal meth. It's personal to
me I want my child home at
twenty nine years old Los
mother and father both died of
aids and the family never got
the kind of help that really
need he needed as a six year
old losing both mother and
father that was traumatic and
now my child is somewhere on
the streets. Once again. After
I bottom hold him up so this is
personal to me is personal me
ever since two thousand
fourteen I spend the night with
homeless individuals the first
Thursday in the month of March
why do I do that. Because one
is not on drugs. Everyone of
you know is not looking for a
hand out people who are are
able wants a job and want to
get off the street the same
thing to each and everyone of
you want for your families a
roof over your head and close
of your on your back. And so
I'm here looking for solutions
so we can try to address. This
situation in our community.
Hello I'm THREE OF US I
represent the east San Fernando
Valley and the state assembly-
you know this issue- affects us
all and I want to thank our
chair. Assembly member Santiago
in all of the panelists that
we're going to learn from to
day- just yesterday I visited a
family care provider. Home
based hell. In my district and
so mark and I learned that one
of the two year olds that was
being taken care of sleeps in
his car. With his mom in the
car. And it just broke my heart
and you know besides the
homeless that we all see every
day under the freeway is run
our sidewalks there's also
hidden homeless. That we don't
see that are in cars motels and
their children and how can we
expect children to go to school
and be ready to learn if they
don't for the going to sleep
that night and- that is
something I've been working on.
And I know that- this year a
lot of us in the state
legislature our goal.
Collaborate together and work
on homelessness. To we can find
a solution help the local
governments with the city you
and I'm happy to be here and
learn from all of you today.
Thank you. Born one of the my
name is my Dillon at the state
senator representing district
twenty four on the city
primarily the city of Los
Angeles and east LA county-
thank you assembly member
Santiago for pulling this all
together so we can. Listen and
learn and hopefully come up
with strong for our- solutions-
I've spent my whole life. As an
organizer with low wage workers
trying to help them get better
for weight higher wages so that
they don't end up homeless the
end up on the streets. I am
really concerned about the
seven fifty thousand families
who wore a severely over
burdened. With the percentage
of rent that they pay from
their income so what we have
to. Our first and most urgent
task is our sisters and
brothers and children who live
on the streets- we cannot.
Address that issue their issues
if we don't also addressed
those who Daly become homeless
on so I'd like to also learn
and hear from as many people as
possible on that thank you very
much. All the members all the.
Thank you all represented here
here today because- we made a
lot of call these folks showed
up in and they've been working
extremely hard on the issue in
Sacramento so we want to thank
them. For to participation and-
in advance thank you for your
hard work this upcoming year on
the issue homelessness- thank
you very much. Wanna get some
help- ground keeping up
housekeeping rules of a members
make sure you turn off your
Michael is that we only have
one person speaking into it so
that you know that it's a live
Mike unless you've turned it
off that way we have the mix of
their- speakers will be called
up about five minutes- numbers
a perverse. Way to. Thank you
it. I'm and also want to.
Clarify what we're here to
little bits okay re provocative
with each other push back in.
And have that sort of
conversation. Six does that
helps us to get to a better
place when it comes to. Solving
the problems I think it's fair
to say that we need- rocked the
ship a little bit. Amongst
ourselves and others to try to
get this. Work done on the show
homelessness- so those ground
rules want- called the first
health. And then I want to say
some thanks but I've been asked
to say the things at the end.
So if you're a- watching my
manners of would not say thank
you to the host and other
folks. I will be doing that
towards the end wimple folks
are present. So forgive me for
that but be patient- and we
want to. Welcome the on. The
first panel. And we've title
this the need for. Urgent
action. And if we could have
will not- Nicolas- director of
center health impact evaluation
for LA county department of
health. And to reset aye aye-
who will introduce herself I
don't have the last name on me.
I and then we'll begin. Okay or
she may be running a little bit
late none the less but if you
can have that. Every in have
you begin and want to talk
about it a sense of urgency.
Yes so yes so will Nicholas
department of public health I'm
here to talk about your other
aspect of this homelessness
crisis which is that not only
are. Too many people sleeping
on the streets too many people
are dying on the streets- we
were pleased to report a couple
weeks ago in conjunction with a
motion. By the board. Of
supervisors to address-
mortality among the homeless-
and I'm gonna I'm gonna run
through our- eggs. Yeah Hey.
And I'm also the V. slides may
be hard for you to see every
slide pretty much every slide
element a show is in a report
that was handed out at the
front by the door so you can
follow along. In the report as
well if that helps. Okay it's
not the. Yeah really work in
here. There it is okay so- all
this is really about- counting
the number of homelessness is
it is a challenge this is a
little bit- in the weeds of the
methods but just so that you
know. The medical examiner
corner investigates the
majority of homeless deaths and
does collect information on
homelessness death certificates
don't collecting information on
homelessness so we did a fair
amount of- hard hard work
digging deeper into the
mortality data from the state
and from the corner to- to get
a better count of the homeless
does which is part in itself
so- we are able to identify
seven hundred additional missed
us that that would not have
been. Found just based on the
most basic information from the
corner. So let me jump to the
data here so. Over the past six
years this is figure shows the
homeless population has been-
the mortality death among the
homeless population has been
rising- from. Five hundred
thirty six total deaths in
twenty thirteen. Two thousand
forty seven deaths in twenty
eighteen that's the number of
deaths but- the actual rate of
deaths which counts for the
increase in the population of
homeless. Folks has increased
by over a third adopting that
same time period so it's not
just the number that's
increasing at the rate. Of per
population- it's increasing in
terms of almost desk and just
to just to might to close. Yeah
okay. There yeah. And just what
is a perspective- in two
thousand eighteen New York City
had about the same number of
homeless in their count- but
only had two hundred and ninety
deaths in two hundred and
eighteen compared to in two
thousand eighteen compared to
bar. Are thousand forty seven
the next thing we did was. To
try to figure out what was
causing this increase in
mortality rate- so we were able
to link the corner dated to-
causes of death in our death
records. And this slide
basically shows the two leading
causes of death among people
experiencing homelessness. Of
the top two causes by you know
by consider margin or coronary
heart disease and drug and
alcohol overdose- Corey heart
disease- indicative of the
aging of our our homeless
population this is a phenomenal
it's happening nationally as
well- drug and alcohol- 88% of
those were words. Were drugs
versus alcohol- also in the top
five leading causes were
transportation related injuries
and- but 82% of those were
among pedestrians and cyclists
so. And then also homicide and
suicide and then we see little
differences across- gender and
racial ethnic groups for
example- among African
Americans corny heart disease
is a lot higher than. Drug
overdose among Latinos drug
overdose little higher than
corner heart disease also among
females- drug overdose of the
higher than than coronary heart
disease. Next we look at. The
trends over time this again is
accounting for- changes in the
total number of people
experiencing homelessness and
county. And what pops out. In
this figure is- the two highest
naturally the corner heart
disease and drug overdose heart
disease which is the red line
is relatively stable so it's
high but not really
contributing to this increase
that were saying so. The real-
the biggest the take home
here's the biggest because it's
contributing to the increase
almost more tell is that the
drug and alcohol overdoses
also- the- transportation
related injuries as the blue
line that's doubled and have so
is homicide is also doubled in
the past six years. So between.
Between overdose deaths-
transportation related and
homicide that's- those are the
those of the causes that are
contributing most to the
overall increase. Next week
because we have information-
from loss said they do a really
good job not only of doing a
home with count but they also
do an estimate of the of this
is a demographic
characteristics of the homeless
population were actually able
to compare for three years
because we had these
demographic data for twenty
sixteen through twenty eighteen
we're actually able to compare-
mortality rates among.
Different racial ethnic groups
of the homeless population- two
things stand out here one is.
Across all three years the way
homeless population mortality
rate is higher the African
American and Latino- rates that
might at first single car
intuitive given that given how
much- how over represented.
African Americans are in the
actual homeless population but
this is something that's been
found actually in in research
around the country it's not a
new finding and the though the
running theory although its
it's- the theory. Is that- the
antecedents to homelessness
among whites verses- African
Americans may be a little
different. With weights- being
more likely become homeless due
to severe physical and mental
health issues where as- African
Americans- experiencing-
economic hardship. And racism
and discrimination so the
they're being that that white
people. Reach a threshold of
illness that's greater and
there are therefore have higher
mortality rates when they
become homeless- also what
you're seeing here is that the
rates going down for whites but
it's going up for African
Americans and Latinos. That's
mmhm. You can this is just data
data just give you ideas for.
For a policies one potential
this might be happening if
indeed. You know the profile of
what homeless folks is that
their sicker and therefore more
likely to screen into-
permanent supportive housing
that's potentially reason why
the rates might be going down
for whites but- again we're in
we're in communication with
the- with the Lhasa who's done
a whole. Report and task force
on African Americans
experiencing homelessness and
so we're- kind of.
Investigating this a little bit
more. Next we also compared by
gender- the rates are going up
for both males and females a
little bit more rapidly for
females especially during the
first year- but again rates
higher overall for males versus
females. This slide is a
comparison of rates just a
simple comparison of the rates
of people experiencing
homelessness verses the general
population of LA county just to
give you a sense of the- of the
magnitude of the of the
problem. So for all causes.
People experiencing
homelessness- had a mortality
rate two point three times
higher than the general
population. Which is a little
lower than what we've seen
another of in the literature
although most of those studies
are from the northeast other
countries that have different-
homeless population so this is
probably an indication of just
the sheer size and diversity of
our homeless population here.
But what's most striking here
is that a for the fight leading
cause of death the it's of
mortality for the homeless or
between three and twenty six
times higher than than for the
general population most
striking being drug and alcohol
over does that's what we found
that more top twenty six times
higher. For homeless compared
to the general population.
Chance lead injuries on the
increase also. Ten times higher
homicide ten times higher as
well. This is a map we've begun
mapping these does these this
doesn't apology doesn't show
the furthest north part of the
county- Lancaster is also a hot
spot- we're doing some hard
going Elsie's we've identified
about- twenty communities
where- where almost S. are
concentrating- and this
analysis is part of a- a
initiative really that were
we've launched here in LA
county to try to prevent
homeless deaths and doing we're
also going to be doing some
more fine grained- geo coding
of deaths within those hot
spots to try to figure out
where where they're happening
so that we can prevent them.
And this is my- the room the
recommendations of the lot of
these are already being acted
on again here in Los Angeles
county as part of an effort
across our health agency in and
other other. Other agencies in
our county. One is we're
working with the corner to
establish a almost death review
panel we're learning from
similar efforts in New York New
York City. To figure out just
to take samplings of folks
who've died of different causes
to understand the- the
circumstances better to help
prevent. The deaths we're
conducting missional a survey
research from the homeless
population we were care harbor
a couple weeks ago and we're
doing. We're with the street
average teams now collecting
information from homeless
individuals and from service
providers. To get some more
insights on reasons. For this-
increase in mortality- we're
looking into. Also we want to
see what the moderates are
people have been recently
housed because those are that's
a that's that's important as
well. We want to. With the
vision zero folks are looking
to reduce traffic fatalities
given that this such a- acute
problem with a with the
homeless in terms of traffic
fatalities. We wanna a tailor
some strategies there. And that
we would just generally want
to. Improve and refine our
methods for on going monitoring
up almost mortality. And that's
said that's all I have for
today thank you very much.
Thank you when you we
appreciate the. The
presentation I know we're
missing a speaker but how about
if I jump in the questions from
the committee members if there
are any
. And reminding
everybody the strikes. The
Hertzberg comment urgency
urgency
. Well let me let me ask
a couple questions- and in the
meantime and- just to be
provocative a little bit if.
There wasn't Barack or see we
didn't have all these
regulations etcetera what would
you proposes an immediate step.
To address- the mortality rate
total out the box are a little
would you right now. What we're
trying to get people house but
in the meantime there's still
dying before their houses so I
would say shelter- temporary
shelter in it yeah. On the
question because we have our
speaker who's right okay with
open. And Theresa Winkler high
you're here as a- as a
testimonial right. Yeah on the
on the need to have urgency so
we appreciate your time thank
you very much. Yeah a of about
as a thank you okay is. My name
is sherry swindler and I was
formally homeless. I've been
in- affordable housing now for.
Over ten years and by the in an
affordable housing I was able
to address. Until illness
substance abuse and- just the.
Chronic pains- the mind body
and soul and spirit. I feel
that it. There were more
shelters and affordable housing.
More people would be able to
survive. Not only just
physically but they will be
able to grow. Productively and
become better people because
I'll. She by giving a person
just sat house it's not a home
show they don't. They don't
want to thrive. But when you're
be when they're able to address
the issues that they have on
hand- medically and mentally.
Well to well okay because I the
median understand I had mental
issues or physical issues in
the last ten years have been
able to address my mental
issues. My health is to improve
job 100% because I've be
hepatitis C. I have no. I have
no longer life changing
diseases thank goodness- and
when I was homeless for almost
twenty five years I wasn't safe
I was in my active drug
addiction I was. Excuse my
language I was process to for
over twenty five years and it
was a side. Show by the grace
and mercy of a loving god. He's
sitting here to testify about
it you know so I feel that if
you had more shelters and more
how affordable housing they
gave wraparound services.
People can thrive and grow. I
think that's five minutes. I
appreciate your- your
presentation I want to take it
back to. Q. a please Mister
Sawyer. Thank you at and I have
my good friend and former state
senator- Kevin Murray who who
is present executive director
CEO of the wind are center in
the back and- he mentioned to
me it up this term called-
service resistant. That no
matter how much we put stuff
out there. There are
individuals. That won't come in
no matter how urgent it is no
matter how many people down the
street no matter how much we
can prove that it is not
beneficial for them to be on
the street. De resistant to
that I was glad to see that
we're talking about actually
talking to homeless people and
asking them what will bring the
men because I feel sometimes
that's a little missing. In
this equation. And I want to. I
know Mr Murray isn't back there
and I don't want to. Take a
bottle of time but if you want
to comment- where Mr Murray's
house I don't know if we he
gets. Personal privilege to. I
think my- my personal choice.
Personal belief on that. Is I
noticed said. Within the last
couple years there's been more
people. Join outreach programs
people such as myself going out
and talking to people. You know
because- the people that go
out. I mean I'm able to sit on
the curb. And talk to someone
who's- suffered or separate and
I can connect because I've been
there done that and tell them
Hey I understand where you're
at but check this out it works
you just have to you know and
then the mental illness cakes
jam or man at a win here that
go away because I was separate.
He said I don't wanna hear that
go way get away from me you
know but- it's how you approach
the people. You know because
like I said. Many times before
dash we're going to get a lot
of people find a lot of chance
with a lot of people dying. If
we don't get more people that
can connect with people you
know and not feeling. I don't
want to feel like I'm in judge
when I'm sleeping in the tent.
Okay because you don't know my
story can't walk in my shoes
you don't know what I have
suffered you know and until you
do. Judge me. Yeah now I'm and
that's how a lot of people that
are homeless fail you now in.
You judge me there's only one
Jack which en I'm- and we all
feel like- I'm not judging you
she why by the way you look at
me the way you talk to me you
know and- people feel like that.
You know when I go into a
store. Yeah I'll tell you this
weekend I had some vouchers and
they were to go shopping with
and I really didn't I was
blessed with those vouchers but
I didn't need them. And I tried
to bless other people with them
and the man was like I don't
need that. You don't know which
might me because one day you
can become that person. Show.
You gotta watch what you say
and how you treat paper treat
people the way you want to be
treated. Yeah because when you
do that your blessings cam.
Yeah am blessing I am is a
preacher okay as I as I said I
suffered twenty five years to
prostitution drug addiction
drug addiction and the wine
garden is awesome I speak here
at least two or three times a
month and I have a meeting. On
Wednesday. Every night every
Wednesday night in the cafe. So
the way you treat be able is
how you'll be treated. Yeah and
if you want to solve a problem
you have to look at the
solution. You know and you
can't solve a problem by just
pouring. Sugar and salt look
the same Xena. Thank you for
everything one more the best
answer I regret. If you don't
mind I want to part my manners
here but I. You took my thunder
by thinking and thank you for
your presentation I was
extremely powerful I have to
say- I want to thank. Is CEO
and president Kevin Marie for
Mike our foundation and it will
thank you very much for hosting
us here and work with us on a
couple of dates. And for the-
more poorly for the good work
it you do here in our neighbor
in our neighborhood thank you.
And I also want to recognize-
supervisor supervisor mark
Ridley Thomas who walked in the
room so. I know he'll be
presenting Mexico. And we may
be running just a couple
minutes behind so I apologize
about that thank you. I want to
at. This I'm sorry I Mister
Gibson and then. Mid miss
Mitchell. A first of all to
recess I wanna say thank you
very much there's no
condemnation. There's no
judging here. We want to be
able to be at a help. And you
know quiet is cap we've all
guilty of something so you're
twenty five years is
experience. That you can share
with people and hope for those
people become hold as a result
of that- one of things I. Want
to make mention of and also-
will you talked about it. The
number of individuals that die
on our streets- and I happen to
know. Personally and intimately
that a number of homeless
individuals. Are targeted- to
be robbed and also to be
murdered. As it because they
are homeless and I had a bill
we work on that deal to bring
it back to the legislature
make. Hate crimes against
homeless individuals I hate
crimes- and that's important
because of my experience
sleeping on the streets and
homes and vigils. Where someone
was tend to run about. One to
thirty in the morning- I was
sleep but my team was up and-
he came branch a gun on two
occasions- and so we know what
happens on the street. But what
can you tell us. About the New
York bottle. One in terms of
best practices. And any of the
best practices are actually
being implemented here. And in
the second piece to the
question as well because we are
now entering into a cold.
Winter the coal mines what are
we doing to get individuals off
the streets into. Shelters so
they will have to experience
the coldness. At present the
question- because of the yeah
we did find that homicide was
to have doubled in the past six
years among this population-
the- we are. Actually have a
scheduled- call meeting with
the New York folks who do
their- their mortality review-
next week and so a lot of the
lesson learning is going to.
Come over the next couple of
weeks so I don't have a trellis
managed to share yet about what
we what we're learning from New
York but I but I would. You
know double the opportunity to
sort of come back the ones
we've had those as I have those
conversations causes all very
fresh- the other questions
about whether in about- about
season out yet we. We did we
get I'm speaking from the data.
Side of things we did look at
the deaths by season to see if
there's any seasonality that
was something that that that
was brought up only percent of
this are there more deaths
happening in the winter verses
this summer- and- we- didn't.
Find any. Anything jumping out
it does it doesn't mean that
there aren't any weather
related deaths it's just that-
we need to look deeper into the
causes of death- but that's
come up several times and it's
something that we have. That we
now know is important to follow
up on in terms of causes of
death- the- folks up in the-
elevator were particularly
concerned gets gets really cold
up there- but also gets really
hot. There so that's also heat
related deaths because of
global warming so it's- it's
kind of a- double. Double edged
sword. But I'm sorry five my
follow up. Okay. I'll talk shop
by we running behind schedule
and the card is to us share.
Okay is Mitchell sorry about
that it's one make sure on
respect for the rest of speaker
so don't leave us. Thank you
Mister chairman I appreciated-
thank you to reset for always
being willing to. Bring your
truth to bear- you spend a lot
of time in Sacramento testified
on bills was good to see it on
I appreciate you. Continuing to
hold us accountable. Dr Nicolas
I'm curious about the slide
here- because it's clear that
there are hot spots indicated
by the red and the yellow. And
I'm curious if you think- it
makes sense because as we know
all resources are limited. That
there should be targeted if you
will for lack of a better term
resources and focus on the
areas that your data shells are
the areas that are in the hot
spots where deaths occur at a
higher rate than other areas of
the county is that. The county
strategy. Yes that's that's one
of them- and it is yet striking
because it's yeah there's a
concentration in the core
downtown but you've got Long
Beach Pomona. Venice Lancaster
I mean it's all the corners of
the county- and so. Yeah our
next step after this is we're
gonna this actually it's hard
to see this red and orange the
sort of the red ones of the-
with the most. Deaths happen
we're gonna go deeper and see
if we can find the
intersections where they're
happening there state on that
as well- yeah anything we can
do to. Turn that our goal is to
bring the number of homeless
debts down you know what at the
same time the warehousing
people we want to make sure
that there's fewer deaths on
the street. And again I'm
assuming. Estrategias to a yeah
dig deeper and focus on. The
higher rate absolutely yeah
thank you. Rivas
. Thank you to
reset for being here and for
sharing your story- you know
the we always remember stories
and it really helps- as a
legislator I'm to hear directly
from someone on that has this
experience- I have a question
for Dr Nicholas on- the traffic
the transportation related
deaths you know I've been
thinking about this lately
because- there was just a van
accident in that killed a
homeless woman in Pacoima in
the San Fernando Valley which
is my district. Are we having
can't meant on freeways I think
it's dangerous and- you dole
and I'm working with Caltrans
you know on the solution and
they do have a process- but I
was curious in terms of the
this increased like you
mentioned that they've doubled-
is it both streets and highways
or you know what can we do in
terms at least their highways
at the state level you know
that's Caltrans I'm curious
what we can do. To prevent
those deaths. Yeah will our
strategy there is we're
fortunate here in LA- that we
have a vision zero coalition
that's initiative that the
city's taken up to reduce-
traffic fatalities vertically
among pedestrians and cyclists
which is over 80% of these.
Traffic deaths among looks
raising homelessness are among
cyclists and pedestrians-
they're spread out there's not
we didn't find a lot of
concentrations of ended they
they're probably a line with
where the hot spots are that.
That they've analyze for part
as part of his and zero- we've
been asking homeless folks-
through our survey effort to
get their feedback on whether
they think there's- you know.
Whether they think that. In a
safe zone should be created
for. Encampments or- you know
more emergency call boxes on
streets we sort of throwing out
ideas and also asking them for
what they they would think
would be important for helping
to. Helping to reduce these but
it's yeah it's striking- again
yeah so it's really mostly
through this vision zero at
adding up up a focus on people
experiencing homelessness in
the in the vision zero plan is.
What we're doing. Remember
members room. The committee
members- cam and over to the
next panel just so we don't
lose speakers- but I don't want
to shy away from the needs
questions we can always refer
them over to the other office
and have some answers this will
be the last hearing either on
and so I want to thank you for
being here and thank you to
reset that was incredibly
powerful thank you for your for
your work. And Mr Nichols thank
you for being here and we're
calling up our next panelist
this is about Kern initiatives
addressing- addressing the
urgency homelessness- we have
with us on a from the LA county
side of the honorable mark
Ridley Thomas we all know he's
been a champion on this issue-
of for a long time and then
fill at answer of the director
of LA county homelessness
initiative. LA city will be
joined in the and shortly by
honorable Mitchell feral and-
Christina Miller who is here
deputy mayor for Los Angeles. A
city. And the mayor's office I
apologize- twenty one thing if
my colleagues okay within about
strike in the sense of urgency.
And I'm not sure my very very
quick story I've- I've been
listening to some of the
podcast you've been on
supervisor Ridley Thomas all
sure my podcast in front of
everybody now. It's really
interesting right now and then.
I want to thank- commissioner
to solve for helping me with
this issue- here's what
happened me in turn terms of
needing a sense of urgency on
the show almost as- a few weeks
ago- right before the rain
started aye aye. Most people
know I walk my speedball. Walk
my dog amble heights and- talk
to the homeless folks and try
to get a better understanding
and- ends up that. I finally
talked to an individual who
wanted help and he said yes I
want help I want to go I want
right now. And we all know how
long it takes to get to that
point. Here's what happened we
called Lhasa and- we call
their- we call fo'c'sle there's
a Hey we really need help this
person he's ready I'm assembly
member away here. The it they
referred us to a website. To
fill out a form and within
seventy two hours will dispatch
somebody. May we need to have a
better sense of urgency than
that and that that. It shocked
me and then so I did what any
person office would you pull
rank. And you say well he I
represent the area I'm
demanding somebody come out
here and- the answer was the
same. Have you fill out this
form. Within seventy two hours
will be sending somebody. And
that has not left my mind at
some of these some of the work
that we do including our work a
half have a greater sense of
urgency that so for that I
thank you of your hard work
because very few people who
have a greater sense of
urgency. On this issue than the
supervisor thank you very much
for your had bird working back
and forth on published achieve
this thank you forgers. Thank
you very much Mr chairman
members of the committee and-
those who are. Here
representing the. Senate we
agree to on behalf of the
county of Los Angeles. Gen with
your permission I'm going to
just. Rifled through these
remarks- pleased to be here-
with so bill and sell who is
the- a counties point person on
homelessness. Of the county's
bench is deep in terms of
subject matter experts. On a
ride he of disciplines
pertaining to. Homelessness say.
It's the locus of
intersectional work for us but
the bill is the of principle
person who is all about
homelessness mess it would
about the public sentiment was
in November just a few days ago
that the Los Angeles business
council released a poll that
showed that 95% Of Los Angeles
county residents pointed to
homelessness is the number one
concern. We thought it was
intense. All right. On the said
lane and I took it too
seriously I guess. We thought
there was intensity in our
polling twenty seventeen- but I
just have to say it's more.
Intense now. A recent poll by
the counties association of.
Governments that is sees that
how poll and the children 90%
of Californians are concerned
about homelessness. PP I see.
One out of every four
Californians believe housing
and homelessness was the most
important issue facing
California today and that
number was more sharply
appointed to. In Los Angeles
county. And in August- I did
some focus group works a would
six focus so- components. On
the county of Los Angeles and
they said it was just simply
urgent and wanted to see bold
action. Brought the work. Of
that poll- that focus who
worked for the committee's
consideration. You heard from
public health one of the things
that is dramatizing the urgency
of the moment Mister chairman
and colleagues is this. One
every single day in the county
of Los Angeles as many as three
people die on our streets
directly attributable to
homelessness twice the homicide
rate in this county. Now that
doesn't get your attention I
don't know what will. It is
startling dated it is a triple
double to the research done by
none other than the county
corner chief medical examiner.
Of the issues guns water
control in this up taking until
corner has gotten in. Trying to
articulate methodologies as
speak to prevention. Bob pulls
the question to you one is a
corner. Do prevention work. It
speaks to the epidemic
implications that we are
confronted with them. Of the
public health ways and says
that they have a bigger
database and sold these numbers
are in that get this
understated. So they went
deeper and some of that you.
Hearing now the average age.
Death is you know was- fifty
one years among the homeless
population against seventy
three of the general population
you died twenty years early if
you homeless. Over an hour.
Just a few weeks ago at an
entity called care harbored
this was- we call this make a
free clinic that used to be at
the form and then it came to
the sports arena knowledge at
the reform. We decided that we
would dedicate one of the three
days. To the homeless
population. And so eight
hundred homeless individuals
were provided direct medical
care everything from dental
visual mammograms name what the
issue might be they got it and
they will hold up out through a
follow on service with a
medical home. The providers
participated in this to help
them get there and so- this is
yet again another way of
dramatizing that people to the
point of service resistance-
it's a missed place debate that
we just cut into that. Thirty
thousand people today are
waiting shelter homes
opportunities and so it is not
my view that we need to focus
on those who may not want to
come and just focus on those
who want to come in and raise
their hands and then we will do
our job and do it well- the
county is funding intensive
case management services for.
Formerly homeless tenants. And
all of news. From the
supportive housing including
triple H. funded projects self
bill we'll talk more about
that- we are engaged in. A
range of- efforts as many of
you know a hundred and twenty
five million operate in drum
housing and shelter sites. We
do that in the unincorporated
areas. And just from January of
the twenty eighteen to now.
Almost three thousand new and
from housing bids and
individuals plus four hundred
and drum housing units just in
the largely unincorporated
areas of Los Angeles county
seventeen to shelters. On the
way- that means another
thirteen hundred people and yet.
I would just scratching the
surface. This isn't cutting it.
Much much more has to be done.
Couple weeks we'll do something
called safe landing- but I
didn't of fifteenth in Normandy
and twenty four seven access-
to outreach teams to bring
single individuals inside and
receive clinically and had
services this is going to be
bridge housing on steroids. And
we need to do more than on the
ground breaking will happen.
But low buildings these are the
innovations we have to do to
get these buildings up more
quickly can happen in four to
five months. On at significant
cost savings. And so I just
want to say that. Urgency is
the order of the day I've said
that we need nothing short. Of
a state of emergency some
reacted to that and said well.
We don't know if we do that
that sounds like an open
checkbook to me well if you
don't want a state of emergency
then develop a comprehensive
crisis response strategy. Get
busy. That's what we have to do
that the executive branch the
legislative branch nothing else
will satisfy this issue in the
county of Los Angeles the
epicenter of homelessness in
the state we because of measure
H. but able to take as many as
one hundred and thirty people
off the streets out of almost
every single day. Only to be
met with a hundred and fifty.
That fall into homelessness we
are losing ground as we speak.
And that's after we put in an
additional three hundred fifty
five million every year that's
on couple we were already
investing. And so it is in part
a question of resources but is
not exclusively a question of
resources I believe where
there's a will there's a way
where this money going to come
from Ridley Thomas well I
think. There are several ideas
and play currently Mister
chairman and colleagues of the
issue is simply this. Of the
prop sixty three resources. An
SSH a we need to re think the
deployment of those resources.
And any county in the state of
California who stopped falling
resources today ought to be
called for. And have to deal
with it accordingly I start
with the county of Los Angeles.
There is no reason for us to do
anything other than to eat that
doubly prudently strategically
deploy these resources so that
we can deal with. Lightly by
the people who are yet homeless
now not everyone agrees with
that. But that's okay I'm
prepared to repeated. The
governor's desk three things of
this task force and that is to
N. street homelessness one and
to break down the barriers to
build more housing is the
second point. And to get more
people into treatment is the
third point the street that's
three simple things that we can
get to those things we will
have earned our titles as being.
Honorable I'll conclude with
the examples that I think can
be made the real one would
think about a comprehensive
crisis response. Versus to
extend statewide and broaden
the authority of A. B. eleven
ninety seven shot up to the
chair will that work. Shuttle
to the city of Los Angeles for
collaborating with the chair in
that pursuit to needy statewide
Siegel relief is important.
Then think we need to continue
to examine a refined- the
interpretation of grade
disability press on to- LPS. It
seems to me that to construct
elaborate arguments that
justified people literally-
expiring on our streets and
their own feces and Bob this is
hugely problematic. We can do
better than that and we ought
to many new that LPS was over
extended. At least forty years
ago one of its own authors said
ten years and we perhaps went
too far far we need to dial
this back it is critical that
we look at that seriously. I
want to suggest that we need to
capitalize on existing public
policy of publicly owned
properties and assets- right
here on Skid Row state owns
property of the city owns
property county owns property
us get role is indefensible in
the day of the week and we are
not accept these conditions but
I refuse to believe that we
have to. I just refuse to
believe that I think changes
can be brought to bear Mister
chairman and I know that you
and your colleagues share that.
Point of view. Our we are
released my phone at this
point. I do want to punctuate
the point that urgency is of
critical nature I did want to
show to the findings of the
focus group work that- were
done. Are just a. Few weeks
ago- creating safe leaving
sites another shelter type
facility was number one. For
those who were in these groups.
Freezing rent levels statewide
was another point. Providing
incentives to landlords to rent
to those experiencing
homelessness and reducing
discrimination against low
income renters was a third
point. Museum publicly and
privately owned lands and
buildings. Became important for
these groups on the use of
groups that were interesting in
terms of- Latinos- and someone
monolingual Latinos others
African Americans- angles.
Disciplines from multi ethnic
groups so there was six
different focus groups and
finally- A. B. group- and so we
looked at this because he
wanted to be in for. And our
advocacy. And I take away from
this and all the other polling
and focus group work. To
underscore the issue of urgency.
A comprehensive crisis response
strategy doesn't that mean that
we have to have a right to
housing- right to write to the
war right to shelter and when
we began this where we thought
affordable housing which is an
aspirational objectives that we
still maintain was what we
should focus on now we have to
deal with short term solutions.
We cannot allow people to stay
on the streets if it takes
three to four years to build
affordable housing that's wait
too long to tolerate we need to
deal with the immediacy of the
moment I thank you Mister
chair. And colleagues.
Supervisor chancellor. Good
morning the honorable members
I'm finance on the director Los
Angeles county homeless
initiative and I appreciate the
opportunity. To speak with you
today. Through their carried
through their board of
supervisors leadership in
launching the homeless
initiative in August of two
thousand fifteen. And accept
the responsibility that is
fragmented among government
entities stepping up and saying
that the county would assume
that role of county wide
leadership. We've been able to
make meaningful progress. As a
coordinated county wide system
we're doing more today than
ever before in helping
thousands as- homeless families
youth and individuals move into
permanent housing. In calendar
year two thousand eighteen
alone the homeless service
delivery system directly helped
over twenty one thousand family
members individuals move from
homelessness into permanent
housing which is double the
number who are helping to
permanent housing before the
homeless initiative was
launched. And we provide aid
I'm outreach services and
prevention to triple the number
of people who were Sir before
the homeless initiative and
measure H. measure age was
approved by Los Angeles county
voters in March of two thousand
seventeen take effect in
October twenty seventeen. With
the board's concurrence we
began providing expanded
services supported by measure
H. three months before the
tactic of fact precisely
because of the urgency of this
crisis. And in the twenty one
minds from July two thousand
seventeen. Through September of
two thousand nineteen. Measure
H. enabled seventeen thousand
eight hundred and five homeless
family members and individuals
to move into permanent housing
and an additional thirty five
thousand family members
individuals moved into an arm
has seen during that same
period of time in arm housing
founded in whole. Or in part by
measure H. so these are
extraordinary numbers of people
moving. Office aids in tener
housing and into permanent
housing and yet at the same
time the crisis is worse. As we
all know from January two
thousand eighteen to January
two thousand nineteen. The
increase in Los Angeles county
homeless population was 12%
That was less than any other
urban area in California by a
lot and still completely
unacceptable absent measure H.
it would have been that much
worse. A supervisor Lee Thomas
noted in each on the average
day of two thousand eighteen
one hundred and thirty three
people every day exited
homelessness in Los Angeles
county through a combination of
the work at home the service
delivery system. And the
resilience and resources of
people experiencing
homelessness who got back into
permanent housing on their own
but on that same average day a
hundred and fifty people became
homeless in Los Angeles county
primarily because of the
combination. Of skyrocketing
rents I'm jazzed evictions and
a severe lack. Of affordable
housing. We are working to
gather in an extraordinary
movement that is brought
together hundreds of
organizations and literally
tens of thousands of people's
across government. Community
providers business and faith
organizations. In a scale that
we have never seen before. To
help people move out of
homelessness we are bailing
water out of this boat faster
than ever before but the hole
in the bottom of the boat is so
large that we are at risk of
this boat sinking and the total
number of our neighbors who are
homeless on the streets.
Continues to grow. So we have
double down continuing to
execute these comprehensive
strategies which are having a
historic level of success in
moving people from homelessness
into permanent housing and at
the same time we continue to
implement. Innovative new
solutions I want to underscore
that there are thirty thousand
people that are homeless in Los
Angeles county. They have been
a stashed and you want to move
into permanent housing. And the
most immediate bear your turn
their ability to do that is
funding for rental subsidies.
It's much faster. J. provide
funding for rental subsidies
then it is to build a new inner
housing facility and it's
cheaper to we can provide
permanent housing not build it.
By provide rental subsidies
India current rental housing.
More quickly and more cheaply
that is the fastest solution to
this crisis. Some of the
specific actions innovative
actions that are under way
include reducing the number of
call county clients who become
homeless by leveraging our
mainstream systems social
services child welfare
probation health and mental
health. The board of
supervisors has adopted the
first permanent rent stabilized
ation ordinance in the
unincorporated areas if any
county in the country and in
California and are incorporated
areas if they were city would
be the second largest city in
Los Angeles county with over
million residents. The words
approved fining for new
eviction defense program for
low income tenants in certain
targeted zip codes I'm working
and we are working
collaboratively with the city
of Los Angeles it is funny is
similar program to implement a
seamless program. In those
targeted zip codes we're
expanding the use of shared
housing. Both as a response to
the cost of housing and the
lack of supply to enable more
people to move from
homelessness into permanent
housing. We're expanding safe
parking and mobile showers and
exploring the establishment of
safe sleep sites to respond to
the immediate needs of people
were sleeping in encampments.
And on our streets. We're
building more interim and
permanent supportive housing
and we have more in terms has
seen and permits supportive
housing in the pipeline in Los
Angeles county than ever before
over six thousand units of
permanent supportive housing
are scheduled to come on line
in Los Angeles county. In the
next three years as the
supervisor mentioned we will
use measure H. to find
intensive case management
services in all of those units
and in those next three years
those will largely be units in
the city of Los Angeles.
Constructed through proposition
triple H. we're taking
advantage Mister chairman and
AB two ten legislation which
you carried in two thousand
seventeen sponsored by the
county of Los Angeles. Where we
are Gen we are now implementing
a new cutting edge
technological solution which
will enable outreach workers in
case managers relying on that
authority granted by the
legislature and the governor.
To look at a person and
determine wider their current
services and what have there
been there passed services from
the homeless services status
system and for mainstream
county departments these are
outreach workers on the
sidewalk talking to people
experiencing homelessness. And
finally in terms of these
innovative actions I want to
note that we're working very
closely with the cities across
Los Angeles county not only Los
Angeles city but the eighty
seven smaller cities as well.
Forty cities in the county that
are home 295% of the county
homeless population that
resides in cities. Have
developed their own
homelessness plans find it by
the county and we're now
finding those cities and their
councils of governments to
support implementation of those
homelessness plans cities in
the county have moved from
saying it's not our problem. To
saying how can we help. And
with all yet with all of this
work we cannot do this by
ourselves with all the
resources I'm press and
resources provided by measure
H. we cannot as local
government. Solve this crisis
ourselves any in particular we
need your continued help from
the state. How from the state
to protect tenants from being
displaced. To increase the
supply of housing and to
provide additional funding.
Fining particularly for rental
subsidies as I mentioned. And
to keep assisted living
facilities open. We greatly
appreciate the work of the
legislature and the governor
last year in particular the
enactment of AB fourteen eighty
to. Enactment of SB three
twenty nine authored by senator
Mitchell and sponsored by the
county and funding for the
homeless housing assistance and
prevention program. But as we
move forward into twenty
twenty. We very much need your
assistance and continuing to
work together to secure
additional state funding and
policy changes which will
enable us to both reduce the
number of families and adults
who are falling into
homelessness. And to help
families and adults were
already homeless moving to
permanent housing. One eight
just reinforces supervisors
comment about urgency and about
our commitment there were many
of that as- I'm in this system
including myself who spent
thanksgiving weekend ensuring
that we would have emergency
shelters open. Ahead of
schedule. For people who are on
the streets during last week's
storms. That exemplifies our
commitment to responding
urgently to bring our homeless
neighbor's home I did reduce
the flow of people and almost
as and with it forward. Add to
continuing to work with you in
this critical effort thank you.
Thank you and I want to
apologize everybody's about
fifteen minutes behind trying
to keep it as close as we can-
and with that gentle reminders
to keep within five minutes all
state over. A couple times
thank you. Councilmember fail
if you'd be on. Okay fund.
Thank you Mister chair and-
honorable members of the state
Senate and state assembly
thanks for having me here today
I'm very very pleased to say a
few words and answer as many
questions as you all might have
I'm gonna give you a little bit
of a progress report on the
production of HHH. Under the
backdrop of. The fact that the
state of California has one
third of the U. S. homeless
population. The state of
California has one third of the
U. S. homeless population. The
county of Los Angeles has one
half of the state's homeless
population just to give you. A
sense of the gravity of and
magnitude of this crises. Up
under that backdrop- in twenty
sixteen just three years ago.
Of voters in the city of Los
Angeles approved measure HHH in
an overwhelming. Majority of
the vote. And out of whole
cloth three years later we have
the ten thousand units. Are in
the pipeline- funded under
construction- with about two
thousand of those units set to
open within twelve months one
calendar year. Do following on
the heels of HHH in November of
twenty sixteen. Measure H.
passes you know in in the
spring. Of providing the
services- the wraparound
services that are needed- at
all of these permits for of
housing sites temporary bridge
shelter whatever it may be. A
funded by the county and it was
Los Angeles city voters that
put H. over the top to make
sure that it would be
successful and pass. Los
Angeles voters a Los Angeles
residents have known for a long
time. That it'll have to be all
hands on deck to really make a
dent in this homelessness
crises that we find ourselves
in- that it was built up over a
number of decades and not years
or months- but none the less
here's what we have- I think as
Mr and Salas just mention. We
have an unprecedented level of
collaboration and cooperation
Anna in addressing this crises
between of various government
agencies county and city. Of
Los Angeles was the very first
city in the state of
California. To create a funds
to address homelessness I and
so I'm very proud of that fact
and then. Some other cities
have followed since that time
we know that Sacramento- has-
taken action as has San
Francisco and on the ballot
coming up- initiatives in in
the spring or San Jose and
Oakland. So cities across the
state large cities are starting
to recognize that. In order to
get control of this double
digit increase in homelessness
your- after year. They're also
gonna have to have skin in the
game at the local level. I
think that it's very very clear
with what we're up against we
know that ten thousand units in
the city of Los Angeles or not
going to house the thirty six
thousand. I individuals who are
on sheltered and on housing- in
the city of Los Angeles we want
to keep this production going
somehow some way. Now I
mentioned that we created this.
Acesse out of whole cloth just
three years later we have. Of
these- these facts to it too
but I think- be very proud of-
however we need much much more-
is so. I've gone to Sacramento
a couple of times will be there
again next month working very
closely with our mayor and
you're about to hear from
Cristina Miller it. On what we
feel makes sense for a- a bill.
Off from the state legislature
and approved by the governor.
Where in we can keep these
resources going- so that we can
keep the production going of
services. Bridge home shelters
and permanent supportive
housing. The one thing that we
always lack and I just heard
mentioned. Thirty thousand
individuals are homeless right
now have are willing to accept
Abed but we do not have the
inventory. As the chair of the
homelessness and poverty
committee on that lawcenter
city council. My main goal is
to produce inventory so we can
get people under a roof without
that we cannot affected fully.
Even talk about ending
homelessness we have to have
the inventory to do that first
we have a whole range of other
issues to deal with we know
that in in in closing we know
that. When the LA times and
other educational institutions
did some deep digging into the
Los account from earlier this
year- it was discovered- there
right in the numbers that the
majority of folks affected by
homelessness have mental health
issues or drug addiction
issues. We have to address that
at the local and state level
along with the production of
this inventory of beds that I'm
talking about I and- we look
forward to working with all of
use the state and the assembly
on helping to craft a bill for
the entire state- but let me
just say one. Has a minor one
more time the county of Los
Angeles has half of the state's
homeless population who wanna
make sure that the resources
that we identify- did take into
consideration. That fact and
that the funding is
commensurate with the need- and
I think that our friends and
allies up and down the state
will understand that because
homelessness is everywhere. In
the state of California as
never before again thank you
for your time and I'm happy to
answer questions. Amir deputy.
And good morning has deemed
committee members my name is
Christina Miller deputy mayor
of city homelessness
initiatives I thank you for the
opportunity and privilege to
testify at before you on the
city's current efforts under
America studies leadership I
also want to thank the state
for the two rounds of the-
state. Block grants heap at
which is the grants at the city
received in twenty eighteen. At
the city has committed nearly
1100% of those funds and that
is far ahead of schedule at the
deadline to commit. 50% of
those funds out was January is
January twenty twenty so the
city is- had a schedule and
making sure that we get those
funds out the door. And since
we are on Skid Row and now I've
mention heat I do also want to
posit- and lift up. The passage
of a recent program that is he
funded at that will target and
black women who are vulnerable
living on the streets of Skid
Row. As a one point five
million dollar program in which
we will target outreach to
vulnerable women who are living
on the streets. And triage them
to permit housing as quickly as
we can another part of that
program is to. Provide cultural
competency training to service
providers to make sure we can
at see what learning some of
can be scaled I'm in this
program that want to look that
up it seemed appropriate and
give the location of this
hearing. And again also I think
the state for the hap grant and
these grants are critical for
expanding the impact of our
local strategies we cannot do
this work without you. And be
very sure what the Ste the city
strategies look like I do want
to underscore and the story
that fill shared about what was
what we are able to accomplish
last week. He gave me a sense
of hope I'm in the speed by
which the city in the county of
Lhasa were able to work
together. And as many of us
were you know settling in for
the holiday to be inside in the
warm and eva family and
celebrate what we're grateful
for. The reality was very
different for people living on
the streets of Los Angeles they
were faced with a very cold
winter storm. And with really
few options in terms of where
to go our winter shelter
program does not begin until
December first- and so it was
with a nimble nest and
flexibility that I don't think
I've ever seen. The city in
casting worked together to open
up. Over eleven hundred need
shelter. For bad. To make sure
that we can provide options for
people who were vulnerable and
second who needed to come
inside. With the bad weather
coming. On this required.
Activating reckon parks
facilities that were never
meant to be winter shelters we
had city staff on on call
twenty four hours a day. The
American red cross stepped up.
And loss that was that was that
you know a major player their-
volunteers recall from the
everyone in efforts okay. It
really did kind of run you a
sense of hope for me anyway
that and what we can achieve if
we do all work together and
look at. This as the crisis
that is. I'm but in the limited
time that I have- I would like
to share some of the work the
city's focused on. Our current
home this budget is four eight
six two million dollars. This
is twenty five times of the
homelessness budget. Was just
four years ago and two thirds
of which- have been set aside
for permanent housing with our
triple H. program. And the mers
primary areas of focus for
street our streets strategies
and tackling and shelter
homelessness. Interim housing
affordable housing development
and preservation. At a place
bass strategy in Skid Row. For
street strategies the mayor has
set up the unified homelessness
response center. This is the
physical space the coal locate
vital for the leadership. Is a
Central Command post to
coordinate the deployment of
resources that interface of
people living on sheltered.
This sounds like something the
city would have had before
right but was just establish
just last year. And we to
playing early eighteen hundred
operations per month that
entail integration of. Services
an outreach with sanitation
resources to focus on
delivering outreach services.
But also to manage- cleanliness
and public spaces. Be unified
with this response center is
the command post also
coordinates operations during
emergencies. AB most recently
with the fires and again with
that the heavy rains. And the
next phase is to make vì you
HRC a twenty four hour center.
Our right now it has normal
business hours but we know
those are not the hours that
homelessness keeps. They do not
at people living on the streets
do not keep bankers hours we
need to have resources twenty
four hours a day. For
intermountain the mers a bridge
home program which was in.
Eighteen months ago has five
hundred nineteen new beds a
bridge housing opens a date.
And a total of twenty four
hundred new shelter beds total
in the pipeline that is thirty
separate shelters that we are-
hoping to have open by June.
Twenty twenty- I'll just
underscore this is the largest
capital program shelter program
that is as the launched in the
country. There's no playbook
with how you stand up thirty
shelters- within the course of
under two years. So we are we
are blazing the trail here. Am
I also invite everyone to visit
the mers website at Ellie mayor
.org backslash homelessness if
you want to track the progress
of those different Bridgetown
shelters. I'm also during his
time in office the mayor's work
diligently with counsel
partners and others to pass.
The affordable the affordable
housing linkage be transit
oriented community programs.
Triple H. at triple H. housing
challenge- which is on its way
to produce over ten thousand
units- of affordable housing of
which eight hundred thousand
will be supportive housing. We
have our first opening at the
end of this month. Fingers
crossed god help us we want to
make sure we get that first
project open in the calendar
year twenty nineteen- there's
also strengthened the rent
stabilization ordinance. Has
reached a goal of permitting
one thousand one hundred
thousand units. Of a housing
two years ahead of schedule.
And in fact in July of this
year LA city was responsible
for permitting 25% of all the
housing units in the entire
state. And we are 10% of the
population. We are tremendous
road ahead of us in tackling
the homelessness crisis. There
is no doubt AB the amount of
groundwork laid over the last
three years has been
astounding. And I say this as
someone who worked in the field
for a dozen years first as a
service provider. On the ground
serving people who were and
sheltered- and it is pretty
tremendous what we've been able
to at least the groundwork.
Growing an ongoing partnership
with the state and identifying
the much needed resources to
truly move the needle and bring
people indoors thank you. Thank
you and then I wanna I know-
the supervisor I one last thing
to say and I'm a handed over to
questions Q. and I'm I'm gonna
go over to miss Mitchell in and
Mr Hertzberg. In Gipson.
Supervisor of thank you very
much was German just of a quick
couple of remarks response your
opening comments about of the
issue of- blossom and it's. On
responsiveness to your- request.
Clearly homelessness is a heavy
heavy lift. I want to say that
it's the case that- loss of
will be going through a
transition and- presumed
restructuring all this is a
matter of public record- and I
welcome it- a lot of work has
been done over the past five
years- but more work needs to
be done- better work smarter
work work defined by more
activation and agility- I don't
think so we were at a-
adequately prepared for what we
are contending with. And so the
amount praise that we may elect
to heap upon ourselves is not
squaring with voters- the
polling that we shared- in each
instance right there is a
pretty heavy dissatisfaction
rate with what has been done-
with- the city's measures some
measure and with the counties
much I think we need to speak
candidly about this in such a
way that we know we have to do
a lot. More a lot more. We need
to assess and real time where
we are chairman. And scale up
our capacity aye innovations
are. Flexibility we've got to
do some things in a different
way now the county has to take
responsibility for its piece of
that puzzle. One Lhasa was
first started the county had to
be brought screaming and
kicking the table to address
homelessness forty years ago.
Is now the case of the county
funds loss at 70% of its budget.
70% of losses resources come
through- measure age and
additional related.
Expenditures so accountability
is the order of the day of the
state has made its way to Los
Angeles and the significant
manner. A hundred and eighteen
thousand in terms of app
dollars projected. Of for this
year sixty five million. For
the county hundred and eighteen
for the city sixty five for. De.
County sixty seven for loss of
there's a distribution of
resources here the speak to
accountability and so while we
all want to say what we are
doing I wish to say we have to
do a lot more and the people of
this region expect no less. We
are obliged to. Thank you
Mister thank you with that-
miss Mitchell Mister Hertzberg
and Mister Gipson. Thank you
very much chairman thank you
all for coming today. And thank
goodness for H. HHH and he- I
tried that goes without saying.
But you know well as I've been
a lot of time thinking about
this you know the reality is
that what we are experiencing
what the whole meal like times.
Indicated is the result of what
I would cut call a slow boil.
We didn't give your overnight.
And I am reminded of my ten
years in the legislature Mr and
sale coming diligently the fact
real every year. Bringing me a
chart that I would hang on my
front door. That show over time
the state's- lack of investment
in cal works the years that we
cut the cal works grant. And a
direct correlation to the
number of cal works families
that were in three homelessness.
For ten years every year would
see that chart out hang on the
front door as a reminder. And
so what I want to talk about or
or or really polls is. Given
our collective agreement on the
sense of urgency today how are
we going to sustain our
investment over time. Because
during tough economic times for
government. Is when the
citizenry in our residents need
government the mouth. So during
that ten year recession when
the state couldn't pass a
budget on time- because member
folks are fighting for these
services and they were forced
with the two thirds requirement
to cut investments that was the
from the beginning of the flow
of oil. That we're experiencing
today. And so how do we all
levels of government the
collective commitment. Because
while the LA L. has in the part
of finance have stated that for
this next year we look release
pretty thought the general fund
we all know the pendulum will
swing. So how do we all hold
hands. Calls our nose in job
and make the promise that we
won't do what. Government tends
to do. Such a government
economic times we cut services
people need the most when
they're broke and government's
broke too. This is a slow boil
so how do we not. Continue to
take full advantage of this
moment in time investment by
not making a commitment to
sustain it over time. I'll just
quickly all say it's a matter
of leadership. If we didn't
have the governor we have now.
In good times we wouldn't be
making the decisions that we
are making of the previous
governor refused to recognize
this crisis. And to the extent
that that is the case exactly
and his predecessors
predecessor and so it has been-
also a conspicuous absence. Of
leadership and engagement on
this crisis now this is not to
say and a whole so matter they
did nothing of value as a
governor's of the state of
California but on this
question- they were.
Significantly absent on from
their post and it is compounded
the crisis in this state from
that assertion I will not
retreat. And nor would I stand
up beside you I just think you
know it's important for us to
acknowledge that there were
decisions made by elected
bodies that we all currently
serve on- that that that lit
the fire a slow boil the fact
70% of section out section
eight voucher holders couldn't
find a place to you about your-
is it. Is a crime the in the
early two thousands we cut the
cal works grant- to historic
lows in my opinion is a crime
and sold a my point is. You
know. The buildings Aug grand
opening sexy I get that and
those are important to do but
there's other work that we have
to do to make sure that we are
making sure that the least
among us continue to have
resources to be able to afford
the rent whatever the right
level. Is that we are
continuing to fully utilize
it'll federal dollars the fact
you know the section Davis
friendly funded we have to make
sure that people can use the
voucher particular here in LA
county when you wait ten years
to get it- and so I just want
us to think. Broadly in
creatively about how we are
allies on this moment in time
on the public's. Focus in
interest and make sure that
it's stained over time that we
don't continue this Evan flow
of investment divestment- that
that compromises. Life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness a
really that I thank you. Eight
dollars need to be revisited I
think general at the state
level. And at the county level
I think G. R. dollars needs to
be revisited and re distributed
you can start there but what we
have. And if we could. Do what
government does it do. Which is
the to think creatively about
our silo funding you know I'm
hoping that the state is going
to be successful in their
eleven fifteen wager
application. To look at the
whole person. And to look at
how we can perhaps use Medicaid
dollars the fund people who are
medically fragile living on the
street so we can begin to
address. Those red and yellow
areas so thinking creatively
general fund dollars to prop
sixty three dollars how do we
make that the dollars fit the
need today. I think it's an
important thing to do. And if I
may senator Mitchell just a
quick response I think a slow
boil is the perfect
description. For what we find
ourselves in right now. And
just let me tell you I couldn't
care less about sexy grand
openings I'd rather not even
have them at all. We just need
to get people under our roof
and that is my focus. But at at
I just want to say that. Nguyen
polling comes out the shows 95%
of Angelinos at the top concern
is homelessness. I think we
could all be involved in
incorporated included in that
95% I can for sure. But what
polling does it makes elected
officials nervous so what I
think we need to do is. We have
to stay the course and make
adjustments along the way. We
just talked about- collectively
the successes we're making I am
not going to second guess
public perception. I respected
I get it I understand it. Up
Bob. As leaders we also have to
make sure that what we know
we're succeeding in. We stick
with. That what we know we need
to tighten up a re visit or
retool we also do that. Along
the way. Because I feel that in
a year's time when we have two
thousand new units of opening
up and- people experiencing
homelessness actually moving
and getting house. Long term
indefinitely. That public
perception will slowly begin to
change. But I'm not sitting
here concerned with public
perception right now. I I'm
concerned with achieving the
will. Voter from to have three
years ago. And the concern of
majority eventually knows how
to get ready. Under Dân of
have I respect that. A long
term what we need to do in this
window where we are
experiencing surplus is at the
St Paul. Is we have to address
some of the fundamentals that
we we've always ignored as
well. I'm sure of a committee
call homelessness and poverty
we held a poverty summit for
the very first time. In the
city's history in September. We
are going to take a look and
we're we're expecting a report
from that summit was extremely
well attended it was a great.
Yeah elle wonderful day long
event with all of the folks the
knowledge base of the lived
experience. Of the experiences
of non profits and leaders in
this industry we're expecting a
report I want to turn that into
city policy. We know where the
pockets of poverty always have
been we also know that we
always neglected to address
that. So we need to focus it is
to be an all in focus. Eviction
prevention- I've more vouchers
so that we can get people in
the housing keep people house
and build. It's an all in
approach let me jump ahead just
so everybody gets that ask some
questions. I want Mister Mister
Hertzberg Mister Gibson and
then I could also please. Thank.
Thank you or contact with
several the- road to urgency in
my judgment. Is government
owned land. The testimony here
today was there's thirty
thousand folks that are willing
to step to take apart take
housing we have is Mr Murray
suggested service resistant
let's focus on the near term
deliverable. Why government
owned land one we're dealing
with the big issue
affordability we live in a part
of the country where things are
quite expensive. If government
can can lease the land for a
dollar a year deals with
reducing rents reducing costs
to taxpayers in affordability.
So second. In the budget
trailer bill SB was at one on
one and German I think. Is the
idea that we expedited the
process for these- navigation
centers in terms of security
you certainly what we've done
with respect Mister Santiago
spill. So we have informed
government policy informed
approach that is are less
expensive- critically
affordability is a big issue.
And certainly the government
policy at the state level the
speed to market to get this
stuff built as fast as possible
or whatever the issues if you
know how we approach it. We
know from the work that we've
done with the city of Los
Angeles through the city
administrative officer the city
owns born twenty eight
partials. We don't know what
the school district has because
we've been trying to get it we
haven't figured out we all of
our two thousand less students
we know have some projects we
just visitors from the been
quite successful with respect
to the- districts. Don't know
what the county has in the
stories that I've heard with
rate to innovation is maybe
something's missed supervisor
talk about but some folks in
the San Fernando Valley pay and
three and four thousand dollars
to the county for. County
property is rent with it should
be a dollar because it's
government owned land which
taught follow up on that I
probably don't know about that.
But but the idea is that they
should focus. Of my office.
Physically with the operation
three thousand one. Forty
portions of government land in
the San Fernando Valley we've
identified a number for the Ste
for the for the that the state
owns. And we know that the
governor was supposed to come
up with an emergency reported
don't know on September with
respect to their- looking at
state property. The bottom line
is that we a flexibility. We
have league we've already
demonstrated that legally
through the actions of the
budget chair. And the governor-
we certainly can do this and so
my only suggestion is and what
I last both the city and the
county that are here today. Is
what are you doing in that
regard. To take advantage of
these extraordinary
opportunities to be able to.
Get folks off the street. And
get greater opportunity quickly
to make this happen I know that
when you came to our meeting at
the LA county- delegation
talked about some ideas of
using parks with respect each
districts- and the like. But it
I just think that that if we
could. We have to show action.
The fact that in favor of fair
that this has been a slow boil.
Fair that that the rate is was
just express. Of people coming
in is greater. Get a life big
deal our jobs to figure it out
and fix it next case. So you
know to me he- I'd like to hear
some insights with respect to
both the city. And the county
as it relates to those policies
what efforts you're engaged in
that regard. Okay. Have a quick
closing towards in and I know I
know Christina Miller has to
leave now represent the mayor
so thank you very much for
participation thank you thank
you very much yeah I can just
quickly speak to some of the
work the city is doing on
leveraging public publicly
owned land because you're right
there is cost savings there
that can bring down the cost of
development that is that is
critical at fifty parcels of
those surplus parcels senator
that you mentioned in the city
were put out to bid as part of
our triple H. program so
developers were able to
leverage the cost of the valued
land. I'm in the city and you
know provided it for
development with a ninety nine
year ground lease. And at and
with. And. I the bill will not
I don't yeah I'm good radios
with. I used to you did manage.
Yeah yeah I'm also to share
with the average I'm program
two thirds of those AB projects
are on a publicly owned land as
well I'm including Caltrans and
metro land and city owned
parking lots that were
identified as good for parcels
for that use so could agree
more I think in the governor's
report and that is either
forthcoming or that has already
been released it there is
minimal state surplus property
that's been identified in LA
city I think it's something
around two properties
unfortunately I'm- but we
always while twenty one in the
county to in the city. I think
we ended cut that coincide with
opportunities. We always
welcome any other you know
public entities that are
willing to leverage their land
for I'm homeless housing and
shelter or programming we are
completely open to that idea.
So think thank you very much
thank you very much I'm handed
over to Mister Gibson just. A
sailor let's. A brief it up and
then a- Mister nozzle because
we still got one panel sure and
I appreciate- although spoken
thus far- I went think. I want
to say that I actually did the
bill that allow the- city of
Los Angeles and the San Jose
to. Have up to ten. Parcel of
land to Caltrans in the
governor brown signed as was
the Los andjelkovic rents
property- that you can build on
for one dollar. A year for
housing transitional- purposes-
with everything is being said I
am convinced we have a state of
emergency. And it will work
clear coat that point and I
want to for the- purpose of the
senators- we have significant
amount of money. In our rating
day fund. That all that we have
to clear state of emergency in
order to access it. That money
is used for a state of
emergency because as senator
Mitchell indicating the
pendulum will swing both ways
or maybe robust right now.
Right who's to say what will
happen in the next couple years
and I'm strongly suggesting.
That we use some of the money-
that we have in our rainy day
fund to address the emergency
that's in front of us. And so I
want to be able to get begin to
at least have a conversation my
colleagues. About the
possibilities of that and also
looking at other- as senator
Hertzberg indicated- government
owned property because I think
that's the best way to go. To
address some immediate needs
right now- in addition to that
I'm going to conclude on this
note- chair Santiago that I
think that we need to also look
at how do we one be able to.
Gets and deal with the sequel-
that is causing what I'm
hearing- developers who have
the option to develop but is
being backlog or delayed- three
years we don't have three years
away first step to be built. We
need it to be built right now
with the a greater sense of
urgency and so that's my
comments and I'll conclude on
that note. Yes thank you Mister
Gibson. I don't need a thank
you everybody I don't need of a
full response to this but if
there's information that can be
shared with us on the issue of
mental health services- that
was not addressed- earlier when
a- on the whole range of the
deaths and the causes of death
and the intersection of mental
health illness with- the
deaths. That are current on our
streets so. Somewhere how does
the issue of mental health
services- get. It should be
given. The priority that it
deserves but I don't know I
don't have the information.
It's just sort of instinct it
mental health issues keep
coming up on the state level-
by many organizations
throughout the state especially
our younger- men and women and
our children are used- the
suicide- issues- it's shocking
to think that in our state this
would be a gross an area of
growth in our in our community
so. You know if there is
information that helps inform
us. A one and that we do
everything that we can do
continue mental health services
in fact increase mental health
services and that that not be
sacrificed. For the issue of
housing- I think that's a
really important issue were a
have a situation and are my own
district right now on that but
we shouldn't have one or the
other we shouldn't sacrifice
one or the other we need a we
need both so that's that's one.
And second is as I mentioned
earlier the issue of economic
development is so important
here we will move our sisters
and brothers to the point of
getting a job. Because that's
the only way they're going to
sustain themselves and we as
government should not think
that forever now up return IT
we're going to have to do the
subsidies to keep families of
float that's not the way our
economy should function so I
think we also need to make the
connection LA was the first-
make the city in the country to
pass a living wage ordinance.
We don't have issues of living
wages come up in this con and
that's really the is a major
issue to keep families from
becoming homeless so. With a
lot of connecting of the dots
but if we don't we and the
solving a problem here and it's
getting worse over here. Just
comments. Just a brief word in
terms of the mental health
work. Of the state of the art
activity that's going on in
that area is behavioral health
centers. That what's the it was
the original Martin at the king
hospital five hundred thousand
square feet. Is now going to be
a state of the art. Behavioral
health center. Loading and-
best practices and mental
health. Of the notion of mental
health urgent centers much
smaller- facilities the issue
of the kindred issue of.
Addictive services cold current
disorder is a lot of that's
going on- senator be glad to
provide you with as much
information as- the county has.
Of the director is John Sharon
I think he's to be here a
little later- he's fully
capable and that but- offices
at your disposal to provide you
with much information. Would
talk about a restorative
village- at LA see USC Medical
Center souls a lot going on in
terms of. Stated the are the
county. Is seen as a leading
the way in the state among all
county the county of Los
Angeles. And yet I want to re
assert we have a lot of work.
To do- miss job we should the
opportunity to be here and-
speak to the- panel and
certainly want to continue this
dialogue and will use it to the
appropriate. Short now I want
to thank you for being here I
want to thank you you too dumb
as well for being here. And as
public servants no the press
that a incredibly pressing on
your time to. Dedicate an
entire morning to it but but I
know that use the same words to
see if we do. And. You know
that for my call one wrapped up
to the next. But when I say
something that Mister- feral
had mentioned and I think. I
appreciate the Paula came out
because it what we already knew.
Your past. And they're angry
and they're frustrated about
about the homeless a situation
and if they haven't lost
confidence or losing it very
very very quickly. I think it's
fair to say look I'm passed. I
mean there's a person in this
room. Was an upset frustrated-
but again I want to thank also
that we're not in an exercise a
finger pointing I think we've
come to the conclusion that.
That bigger points on could
help right I mean it's not
going to solve anything it sexy
it. But you know blow the
whistle you get a quick press
said. The world workers in
challenging challenging each
other to. To break down
obstacles to get this- the get
this is this humanitarian
crisis under control I think
it's fair to say we can call it
a public health crisis has been
denied- you because they have
to be- has to be taken a look
at like a public health crisis.
It is a state of emergency. It
in and I'll tell you I think
it's one that that needs to be.
Attacked in a compassionate way
so when I say that that I'm
angry. It comes from a sense of
compassion because we have now
we've got to figure out how to
do this if the least among us
doesn't have. A roof over their
head food in their mouth- away
to care for their kids and
we've we've certainly failed
society. And animal and a
multiple ways. Look I we put
together a list of what the
state has done. And it's
expensive and the reason I put
this list together- our folks
put together one of the
governor's office it is it is.
To make that point that had
been made by- many of you
there- that we've got to figure
out a way to blow up the system
and start a love in a way that
actually addresses- the very
contact points that help
people. Because we keep
throwing money at this problem.
And at some point time we got
to figure out the most
effective use of those dollars.
And all point that this and I
know miss Mitchell knows this
inside and now. But when you
take a look at some of the
dollars that a bit that we keep
putting at this. It's the and
at the state level we can go
from emergency. Solutions grant
and you guys should all have it
in your in your- in your
notebook and we'll take a look
at. A sixty two million this
year the housing and homeless
prevention- seventy. Three
hundred and seventy million was
appropriate two hundred and
seventy million left. No place
like home- we got about two
billion coming down the
pipeline. Cal words that sound
like I'm reading your report
right- hundred and- twenty four
million last year what this
year- the multi family. Housing
I mean go on and on it's a two
hundred seventy seven million.
The. Five million to address
homelessness within the act of
two thousand eighteen out five
hundred million. Five hundred
million it's this year at six
hundred and fifty million. And
I go on and on and on and the
millions and millions of we
start adding it up. I've been
added it up but for somebody.
But my guess is by about four
to five billion at the state
stone in over the last couple
of years in one. Way or the
other. But you know it's also
daunting is if we don't keep
drumming that beat we're not
going to create that sort of
excitement as sort of- fury to
get this stuff done out. Of
talking my colleague earlier.
But three years ago. Our caucus
took a poll of what more the
most important issues. It was a
scientific poll which is kind
of. You know we all got to
stick as we one put up. I think
of like maybe one third of. The
members in that room at.
Thought that homelessness is
even an important problem. One
third while some of us were put
in both of our stickers on that
and- try to steal someone
else's sticker to make it. To
make it more of an important
issue but that's the kind of
work we got ahead of us number
one it's- it's convincing on. A
convincing. Everybody around as
a we got a knock down all those
beers even if it's painful to
ourselves I want to thank you-
to da. Are you done in there
and other the mayor's office to
Cristina for helping us to. Try
to figure that out I think next
year- have will be. Taken out
that sledgehammer knocking down
those obstacles. To ensure that
that people are house- with
with. With some sort of dignity
and that mental health care
issues- are beginning to. Their
trust in a more more much more
aggressive- manner and that
substance abuse issues is. At
the top burner so thank you
very much I. And I'm gonna go
to our next panel so I want to.
It Mister. Mister chair. If I
may. This could only in the
interest of the other panelists
I wanna make sure that they're
not going to leave us. But all
deferred it to ms Rivas. It's
gonna make a brief comment. Of
you know I'm looking at our
state investments and thank you
to the chairman. For
summarizing this but I think.
At what I see at the state
level we don't have a
department. Or a state agency
that has oversight right there
or side load or different
agencies and- I think it's time
for. The department on
homelessness at the state level
right. To coordinate all of
these. Are programs- and- and
for there to be oversight
accountability and strategy
with working with local
governments- so. I just wanted
to get one and this is just to
remind us all you know the
state does have- it was a model
we lifted from Utah. On
introduced a bill several years
ago the state does not have a-
homeless coordinating council
which because if they had
nothing. So at least now we
have a coordinating council.
Because another critical issue
is holding state department
heads accountable. For figuring
out what role they play
Caltrans director is a perfect
example in solving this issue.
In addition to. Looking at you
know already allocated funds
that could be directed in this
area so while we don't have a
state department or agency. The
coordinating council was
funded- by this administration
in a significant way that had
not been previously so I think
that is the first step in a
signal that the state is.
Really trying to step up and be
a partner with local
government. To be our last
brief comment. Mister chair. I
would like to leave with this I
think the center Hertzberg
delighted an enormous
opportunity you mentioned LAUSD.
LAUSD is the largest
landholders in the city of Los
Angeles when you combine that
with the state- college of. The
city district. They get
committee call just thank you.
Up all of those land use
decisions are ministered by the
state there's a state agency
that that administers a
planning and land use for all
of those properties- we've had
some great successes with LAUSD.
And between- UST and all you-
this is the state college
district alleys yeah thank you.
There should be no surface
parking lots left we need to
build housing and parking on
all of those sites that's a
government owned property. Lake
that's a golden opportunity and
perhaps that's another bill
that could be introduced but
that could be something that
would really take a bite out of
exactly what we're trying to
address and that is taking
state property. And building on
it without a loss of parking-
that can be accomplished and
there's an enormous
opportunity- there thank you
well here's what I get from
this conversation this is gonna
be the first one it certainly
isn't the last one and I feel a
heck of a lot of energy and
enthusiasm for continued it
callin. Balls and then up I
thank you very much big round
of applause you take out the
morning. And. We get what I'm
open the next panel still here.
And I'm gonna call them up in
the order on if you just line
up I think we're putting
another table up there as well
right now it's doctor Sharon.
Miss best an honest assault
miss Leslie. Miss Ramsey Mister
Harris. Missed. RAF starts my
glasses any bring and- miss
rock as. Thank you thanks
. But
right now it's okay.
Assemblyman
. I think you got
the right
. Here's the list
Mitchell fully make
. It's
worked. For over the road
. I'm
gonna get started on what this
what what the next pounds about
what we really wanted to do was
provide the committee and
provide ourselves- you included
a different perspectives and we
wanted to make sure that we
tackle they've not only from a
local government I'm gonna
continue here from a local
government despite we wanted to
see housing advocates a
philanthropic advocates
government- in all you folks
are here combined together and
obviously the county still on
it and a law enforcement so
everybody around the table here
brings a unique perspective.
Overly look how to challenge
this issue of homelessness and
actually actually have a
significant dent in it I'm in
the interest of time I'm gonna
handed over immediately-
conductor shared will ask folks
to stay at their allocated
amounts I think we told
everybody try to stay five or
underneath and but a quick Q.
and a if you had to leave just
let me know and because I
realize is done just a little
bit oversight Preciado. Thanks
very much. To be here. And I
will have to run after my
comments because I'm supposed
to be testifying at the board
of supervisors about. A motion
to expand the number of mental
health treatment beds in Los
Angeles county. After just
completing a report. With
numbers around three thousand
beds and getting authorized in
my department. To bring five
hundred more online. Also just
make a quick remark- related to
mental health issues and death
in. The streets and actually
addictions and. A trauma our
our our our primary drivers and
co morbid mental illness and
addictions are obviously
critical I'd like to make
another quick comment regarding
senator. Senator Mitchell's
point about sustainability. Too
many people are becoming
homeless. We have a massive
amount of collaboration and
effort and resource going into
housing people and we it
shouldn't have to be that big
of a number. To sustain
includes figuring out ways to
not have to house that many
people especially when we're
losing the other thing I'll
tell you from my perspective
around mental illness and the
number of people in the streets
of mental illness mental
illness is not one thing.
There's a range of mental
illness people live in the
streets for long periods of
time we'll developmental on
this because it's a
traumatizing experience.
Individuals with what we would
call severe persistent mental
illness that's a smaller
percentage than the numbers
that people throw around and I
think we have to be aware of
that. I am here on behalf of
the most vulnerable on it
recognizing that there are
multiple populations who are
homeless and that we have an
epidemic. And I think one of
the things that is happening.
In certain. Populations is
that. There that the people are
choosing to not be. House and I
we have to look at that there
are a lot of difficult
questions and topics that I
believe. Is one of them and one
of the prop one of the reasons
that's a problem is because it
draws resource that we need for
folks who are the most.
Vulnerable the other thing I'll
say is that it's not just about
new develop and I'm really glad
to hear that theme here we have
the leverage the infrastructure
that exists. We have to
leverage it through things like
the boarding care network that
many of us are trying
desperately to save. We have to
look at as filin cells said
subsidy. For housing that
exists because we need to get
it out sooner and we get need
to get it out. Cheaper as far
as people living on the street
and this is a very
controversial topic people
living in squalor are actually
increasing the demand and then
we need. We're losing when
people are living in squalor.
Because people are getting sick.
Gauge for how bad it is it is
the death rate which is going
up. People need a right to
refuge and refuge. In my
opinion is something that we
don't fully understand and
implement because it doesn't
have to be. Permits part of
housing unit it doesn't have to
be a shelter bed we have to it
we have a epidemic on our hands
were collecting more and more.
Illness and condition for
people that are suffering in
squalor we need to leverage our
properties and do the kinds of
things that our military does
when there are. When we're
going to battle and we're
taking on major emergencies
that's a different way and a
different approach to get it to
replacing the sidewalks. With
place where people are not
traumatized where they have
more access to services more
easily and they're not getting
sick. In terms of mental health
treatment beds and mental
health resources in general
supervisor Ridley Thomas
mention to be able health
center we are trying to
leverage our health care
campuses to developer sort of
your villages. Across the
county this department has
invested. Over three hundred
and fifty million dollars since
I've been here in restorative
care village asset and that
includes urging Kerr's as well
as- acute subacute and open
transitional units we've also
put in. A couple hundred
million dollars into- into
permits part of housing and
development as well as services
which we do. Every year but my
focus is on the people who are
the sickest in the most
vulnerable and I think what we
have to look at hot spots where
people are dying we also have
to be click here. In focusing
on those who are most most
vulnerable who are the least
independent in who will who
have almost no chance. Of
getting into permits part of
housing unless they give we
give them a serious hand up
will also say in this one is
very close to the heart of a
assemblyman Santiago.
Involuntary treatment okay we
have to. Revisit those laws and
we have to go after them with
empathy and heart we have to
put our resources first and
commit. Anyone who is a rights
we're going to take away. We
need to meet them with
resources up for but we have
direct ties those are not. Too
loud. Close those who we cannot
engage. Despite trying again
and again we have to be able to
figure out a way to get them
into treatment and to get them
into treatment to help foster
their recovery in the only way
you get people to recover is by
giving them resources and I
mean housing I mean egg
dedicated treatment team. I
mean. The hospital beds when
they require them and a very
well informed and resource to.
A surrogate decision maker I
don't know how much time that
was but I'll stop it was good.
Thank you yeah. Hi I'm sorry
taught are often with the LA
county department of health
services and- with the housing
for health program within the
department health services of
the last few years we built out
a continuum of services from
out reach to and from housing
to permit housing with a focus
on people who are homeless and
how the most complex health and
behavioral health conditions.
And I just want to sort of- to
make it very concrete share
that over the last couple of
years that I've been with
housing for health we have-
gone from a situation where our
outreach workers could engage
somebody on the very same day
and move them into in term
housing and have it bad for
them that same day and be able
to assist them into permanent
housing within a few weeks or a
couple of months. Managing a
portfolio of about twenty four
hundred intern housing beds now
today what I can say is that
like that stay in and from
housing bad has shifted from.
Maybe sixty to ninety days for
we have clients are stained six
months nine months even twelve
months because we don't have
the back door for that we don't
have the permanent housing for
them to move into- we- that the
construction new construction.
Of affordable and permanent
supportive housing is a very
big part the solution fully
maximizing every federal rental
subsidy is a very important
part of the solution. I'm also
just one elevate something that
was touched on a couple of
times here today which is
investments is sort of like-
local rental subsidies- we
operate the flexible housing
subsidy pool. Which is a way
for us to very quickly move
people back into housing. Is
very flexible it's very nimble
were able to provide rental
subsidy support it could be
short term until some to get
back on their feet it could be
longer term if somebody needs
it could be a bridge to. A
federal subsidy but what it
does is it opens up the
existing housing market.
Buildings that already exist
private property owners who are
willing to take the subsidy.
With knowing that they will
have. Us behind it and a half
according to behind it who they
can contact twenty four seven
if there's any issues with and
it's a- really opens up a lot
of units we just held serve at
love eight. The investment of
the potential for investing and
stuff like flexible. Housing
people as quick based
. I had. A
path others this bull- thing.
And then- also I just want to.
Very briefly talk about
boarding care- this is a really
important part of the house to
continue- especially for people
who are homeless in of really
complex healthy behavior health
conditions- you get the
housing. You get support with
your activities of daily living
you get Rick mind or to take
medication you get
transportation assistance is
just such a key part of the
housing network for certain sub
population of people who are
homeless. The crisis in our
boarding care right now is huge
the- it takes you know you know
the average private pay for
boarding cares about four
thousand dollars per month per
client- most of the clients
were talking about who. Going
into here with these complex
issues are using a site that's
paying about a thousand dollars
a month. That's thirty five
dollars a day that is less than
what we April from how kilter.
And we're asking the sites to
do so much more terms of the
care and support of people who
are really complex. Up not to.
Pull they cannot do the
deferred maintenance. What do
you the note people at that
rate- who really need those
settings so we need to figure
out how to shore up our
boarding care terrace of. Them
with deferred maintenance and
how to get enhanced services
connected to those clients so
that those boarding cares are
sustainable and continue to
operate. Thank you. Mr about.
On
. Got it okay of someone four
minutes and thirty seconds rest
assured of time to twice okay
good morning chairman Santiago
members of the assembly select
committee. A Los Angeles county
homelessness. I'm Robbie Harris
a director with the Los Angeles
police protective league that
represents approximately ten
thousand police officers from
the rank of lieutenant. Down to
the recruits in the academy.
Appreciate appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you
today and I'll be focusing my
comments around St that you've
probably heard before such as
Houston we have a problem. And
how do you eat an elephant. And
last don't reinvent the wheel.
In two thousand and eleven the
city of Houston have the sixth
largest homeless population in
America. The point in time
homes count and survey
identified eight thousand five
hundred and thirty eight
homeless individuals that year.
Many of these individuals are
in need of drug abuse mental
health services and we're not
receiving the care they
desperately needed. And police
officers were dispatched to
somehow trying to help and
manage a growing crisis.
Houston was spending a hundred
and three million dollars
annually at the time on fewer
than fifteen hundred
chronically homeless
individuals. The chronically
homeless individuals comprise
less 20% of the homeless
population yet you seventy five
percent. Of the public
resources. Veterans also made
up a large portion of Houston
most population. Senate leaders
soon declare Houston we have a
problem. To address the problem
the heads of the Houston and
Harris County housing
authorities. Directors of city
and county housing development
departments the VA service
providers and community based
organizations funded to do
local veteran work sat at one
table and talked. They created
housing Houston's heroes and
their initial goal was to
permanently house one hundred
veterans in one Hundred Days.
They realize that it took over
one hundred and fifty different
steps for homeless veteran to
navigate before getting
shelter. From securing a photo
ID a birth certificate to
filling out almost identical
paperwork for the housing
authority in the VA. The local
governments VA and service
providers works together to cut
the one hundred and fifty steps
to fifty or sixty. And help the
veterans navigate the entire
process. In two thousand
fifteen the city of Houston
declared a virtual end. To
veteran homelessness. And this
past year's point in time
homeless count and survey
identified three thousand nine
hundred and thirty eight
homeless individuals. Down from
eight thousand five hundred and
thirty eight that's a 54%
decrease in over a homelessness
since two thousand eleven.
Houston focused on a ratty
kidding veteran homelessness
they also kept working hard at
reducing homelessness across
all other population groups but
they zeroed in on the veterans
and they succeeded. In Los
Angeles the numbers are so
daunting it's like being asked
how do you eat an elephant. My
suggestion is to do it like
Houston did one bite at a time
and focus on the three thousand
eight hundred and seventy eight
homeless veterans the LA. Times
reported were homeless this
past veterans day. We all know
the benefits of housing are
homeless. You have heard and
will hear the numbers budget
implications and obstacles that
stand in the way. The
inevitable turf wars blame game
and finger pointing can consume
a thousand hearings just like
this one. But now we know where
there are successes in
addressing this humanitarian
crisis so let's go there. Said
our egos aside and bring back
what can work. Salt Lake City
Phoenix and Houston. Have all
had measurable successes in
reducing the homeless
population. Each of those
cities has declared a virtual
end to homeless veterans on
their streets. They have a
housing first attitude shelter
first then the services and
support. In fact the mayor of
Phoenix Greg Stanton believes
that the most important lesson
from the success of the Phoenix
model. Is that it can be
replicated in any community in
America and I believe them.
Let's not reinvent the wheel.
In Houston they created the way
home a collaborative model to
prevent and end homelessness.
Their website is the way home
Houston dot org. I encourage
everyone to take time and look
at what that city is done. And
there are probably others that
are moving the needle in the
right direction and we should
be open. To doing whatever is
legal and ethical to rapidly
adapt what we are currently
doing to check achieve success.
I urge this committee to find
immediate funding and dispatch
local and state decision makers
and community based
organizations to Houston to
Phoenix to Salt Lake City. And
see what the cities have done
what they are doing and let's
duplicated Los Angeles. We have
a problem. Thank you. I think
missile. Mister Harrison
install next thanks. Hi I
promise we didn't chat before
about our remarks and what's
interesting is that- we have
lots to has hired the person in
Houston who worked on that
program and she has been
helping us with our strategic
planning and really looking at
how the flow chart and how do
you cut steps because that's
really the bottom line on I
wasn't planning on matching up
but I think that's important
set to bring up because I think
we can learn from on the other
cities and other counties. And
I just think we have to
approach this calmly nobody has
all the answers we've got
obviously we're here to do more
and that was the question that
you asked of us I want to thank
you all for listening today and
for the work that you're
already doing I'm gonna just
rapid fire some ideas because
the question was posed to me
what more can we do I'm and
what can we do to try and
sustain more. I will just
quickly tell you aye approaches
work as someone who's advised
very selected officials as a
deputy mayor a policy a but-
but it's really my personal
experience that is giving me
the most exposure my brother is
experienced homelessness
because of six or mental
illness for the last twenty
years he's currently in jail I
twenty hours he's awaiting
placement in a state hospital
so you're talking about these
LPS laws and other laws I'm-
deeply from your with some of
the challenges. And they are in
your hands on to be a. Really
for the- ache. Amid. Bob let.
Coming home life then to
address it once they become
homeless I'm I'm brought with
me so- program that Lhasa has
just launched in collaboration
with the county and I'd love
for you guys Ted take a look at
it get it out to your
constituents and see if this is
something we can expand on a
greater level it's just called
basic problem solving it's
another form of diversion but
it's trying to meet people
where they are in housing. And
see what what's it gonna take
through creative crisis
management through- through
conversation what's it gonna
take to keep you in housing so
that's something I'm gonna
leave you with here today on
the other thing I want to
highlight which has been
mentioned by several people but
I'll take quickly is just the
boarding care units I
understand that you guys are
looking at this AB and flow and
for the Burke guards to funding
but I'll just give you the
brass taxes we lost a thousand
units. If you multiply a
thousand times thirty five
dollars per day. Time three
hundred sixty five days. You
have twelve point seven
million. So there's twelve
point seven million in savings
from that budget line item.
That could be put towards
saving the rest of those units.
In LA county. And in other
counties I'm sure experiencing
the same issue. So I'm not
saying you even necessarily
need to look at and investment
beyond. The investment that
you've already budget. I'm just
saying look at that budgeted
amount. And start to figure out
how you can allocate those that
those dollars. If I'm wrong I
apologize think about a
different way. Excellent I I'm
sure it's more complex but I
just thought I'd point out the
fact that we've already lost at
thousand units. The other thing
that you guys have all done
each of you that is remarkable
as your work around tenants
rights. And we really
appreciate that here in LA
county but I do want to
highlight on that Ellie city in
LA county are working on
greater access to legal advice.
On through a variety of
measures how important that is
before coming here today I
spoke with one of the public
interest lawyers that's working
with las at around prevention
issues. And she specifically
mentioned to me about a family
who went to the Norwalk
courthouse last week. File
their paperwork around an
unlawful eviction. Did not get
the correct advice to file for
a fee waiver. Later told your
owing two hundred euro two
hundred dollars to file. Tape
by this addiction. They left
the courthouse because they
couldn't pay the two hundred
dollars. So without access to
good legal advice. The amazing
laws that you have passed will
not have the effect you want. I
the other thing I wanted to
just point out is take piggy
back on some of the
conversations around. Access to
immediate housing options. And
I appreciate senator Hertzberg
comments around any type of
government property is
incredibly useful that cuts
costs it also can help expedite
the building of those units. Or
their their location of safe
parking I just wanted to make
sure that is also highlighted
today. Whether it's cabin
communities motel conversions
sprung structures. Safe
parking. The all of those needs
we need more of it. On the
other issue that we've been
working on it loss that is more
rapid re housing so it is
someone who as or family who is
actually become homeless. But
again through a smaller level
of subsidy we can rapidly re
house them and that's something
that's proved effective
throughout. Throughout a lot of
different neighborhoods and I
want to encourage that on to be
expanded. The other thing we
haven't talked about is housing
options and rental assistance
for those who don't meet
federal criteria based on their
immigration status. Federal
programs are really targeting
folks and I wanna make sure
we're aware of state funding
and local funding being used
effectively to fight back. We
raise this issue of why were in
so deep a hole I just want to
be clear the federal government
continues to cut and has cut
housing subsidies over the
years to the tune of seventy
percent. So that is an issue to
keep front and center. We also
need to look at on incentives
for smaller cities to do more
Phil and sell did a great job
of talking about the ways that
the county is looking at-
encouraging that. I know
several of you are working with
some of the smaller cities and
I just want to encourage more
of that. We do need a higher
level of care for most
vulnerable and I appreciate Dr
Sharon's remarks around the
mentally ill obviously I
experience that daily with my
brother. On and the innovations
that were working on
specifically in your district.
On center draws so where are
exciting. On but we also need
access to substance abuse
treatment. On and that is a
huge issue on the on at for
many populations. Are gaps
analysis coming out of Los at
the end of this month it's
going to be talking a little
bit more. About on. The
specific details around the
housing needs for some of our
most vulnerable. So I just
wanted to highlight that and
will make sure to get you a
copy. Please continue your work
around eliminate lake
eliminating regulations that
get in the way of immediate
help. So your work on SB eleven
ninety seven was critical we
need more of it. On at some of
the bills that you guys are all
working on it been. Are great
and we're excited about but as
I said federal cuts at 70% we
need to look at some permanent
support said support for.
Affordable housing whether
that's SB two I know you are
looking at tax increment
financing for SB five. Those
are important on vehicles.
Finally I had the honor of
serving on the commission with
Jacqueline Wagner from
enterprise foundation. She
could not be here today.
Through her leadership and many
others listed on the report
that I'm gonna leave with you.
Los the launch the ad hoc
committee on black persons
experiencing homelessness. The
goal was to listen and to
create understanding around
black people are significantly
over represented here locally
and nationally by those
experiencing homelessness. The
answer is simple and yet
complex. Structural racism has
played a significant role. The
report put forth sixty seven
recommendations some housing
assessment tools are missing
cultural competency other ways
of getting better access to
immediate housing. And we're
beginning to take a hard look
at that issue and many other
recommendations but we won't
win if we don't create systems
that work for absolutely
everyone. I want to leave you
with a copy of that on
hopefully I've got copies for
everyone thank you. I think it
was a. Well thank you I merry
Leslie in prison a Los Angeles
business council on an honor to
be here today thank you
chairman Santiago for inviting
us here and also for all of you
being here today- it's my
pleasure to share some of the
key findings of the- L. A. B.
C. institute LA times and UCLA
poll you heard quite a bit
about it today- I think each of
the committee members have. A
short version of the graphics
in their pockets for those of
you who do not have a short
version you can go to our
website at LA this is counsel
dot org on the pole is- there
it's available is a transparent
it's free please spend quality
time with it but to just give
you a few high points as polls
conducted in October it was
over nine hundred one
registered voters in LA county-
the key findings of the poll
I'm just going to mention a few
highlights some of which are to
mention today. This is probably
first time we've ever seen 95%
as a number ever ever ever.
Ever ever okay so. I think and
the key about that is it's
everyone it doesn't matter if
you're conservative it doesn't
matter if you're moderate does
not if you're liberal. You
agree that this is the number
one issue. Facing LA county
it's also impacting the mood of
the county as a whole. Majority
say they are personally
affected by homelessness a
significant number of people
say. That they have experienced
it recently many voters feel or
most of the voters feel
empathetic towards the homeless
and most tended thing. Societal
factors not choices made by
individuals or the root of the
problem. Or not blaming the
homeless. Well a lack of
affordable housing is seen as a
major grow- growing problem
voters are even more likely to
point to the lack of mental
health. Services as the met
major driver of homelessness.
Voters voters have not lost
faith the pop on campus all.
Large majority support of
writing concrete options both
systemic and contemporary
voters want forward thinking
solutions that will actually
fix the problem over the long
term. But at the same time
there is a high degree of
urgency around the issue and
large majorities want to see
the city take quick. Tangible
steps to address it. Even if
the changes require additional
resources or- or affecting
their own neighborhood. I would
ask you to look at the top plan
results of the poll you also
have that in your packet for
the committee members on. We
also a few questions. These are
basic questions if more than
five hundred thousand new units
are needed to meet the current
housing demand which proposals
would you support a range of
options were supported by more
than 60% of the voters offering
incentives to apartment owners.
To keep rents low promoting
more affordable housing by
allowing greater density along
transportation hubs and
supporting a rent control
ordinance to keep pace with
inflation. We ask voters about
the legal right to shelter or
housing 75% of them supported
requiring the government to
provide temporary shelter. To
any homeless person who wishes
to come indoors we test is
support for what other cities
have been doing to address the
homeless problem this got a
resounding- response of more
than 70% Favorite speeding up
development permit support of
housing such as apartments
built out of factory built
modular. Units teeny houses
trailers and other structures
using emergency relief tests
like those used by the red
cross and FEMA to bridge to
more permanent housing. Opening
up National Guard armory and
using public property for
temporary shelters like we do
for other emergencies providing
public bathrooms and showers to
support homeless. Residents as
they live on the street in the
neighborhoods using shed light
cabins community cabins quipped
with cots electricity and
plumbing as temporary housing.
For up to forty people at a
time until individuals are
connected to permit housing and
allowing conversion of single
family homes to dorm. Style
developments were multiple
tenants share common areas.
Then the LA you see I'm I'm
doing this in two and a half
minutes three minutes I suggest
you take a look a longer look
at it I'm trying to give you
the high points we then
discernment that we at our
eighteen to and we don't
housing some of it two weeks
ago on we create a call to
action so what do we think
based on the poll results in
the years of our research and
advocacy. We think that it's
time- to address this issue
with urgency innovation
collaboration for those reasons
we believe the following
actions should be considered by
you all- we agree with
supervisor mark Ridley Thomas
and they're Steinberg that it
is time to enact a legal
imperative to provide a roof
for every homeless individual
and family. We think whether
it's a shelter bridge housing
navigation centers I support of
housing every Angelino should
have the right to a roof over
their head ultimate goal of
being placed in permanent
supportive housing this legal
mandate must be paired with
wraparound services to address
health and substance abuse
issues. To begin funding this
imperative we believe the state
should make an emergency
appropriation of two billion
dollars Mitchell for matching
funds for local jurisdictions
to fund the development of
twenty thousand units of
emergency shelters and bridge
housing Acosta listen hundred
thousand prepare. For the long
term the state should find a
permanent source of funding for
homeless housing similar to SB
two for affordable housing we
support mayor Steinberg and
really Thomas is just and that
reallocation of a large portion
prop sixty three for mental
health services if needed. This
thing should be call related
with a plan for LA to get our
new Reno targets which were
just just happened last month
which include four hundred and
seventy six thousand income and
affordable units for LA county
under 110020% of a online we
have never. The number like
that. That means we. Thirteen
the estimated- last week in a
report they release that that
would be up the hundred thirty
four billion in subsidy. As
homelessness is not confined to
single municipality we would
encourage the expansion of AB
eleven ninety seven thank you
chairman and- at least to the
borders of LA county if not
statewide we must look at
incentivizing low low cost
construction types. On namely
modular housing with the
average cost permits were
housing being roughly six
hundred thousand we think the
cost could be greatly reduced.
Currently the barriers in
California or that we don't
have a lot of it we need to
look at how we're going to on
incentivize modular housing and
state. And for a man's for
advanced manufacturing
facilities in here in LA county
to create more jobs finally we
think. We should build a
success along of short term
solutions like the sprung
shelters with bunk beds as
successfully used in San Diego
San Francisco Pomona Fresno and
look at Oakland's community
cabins all dramatically
increasing the number of
housing units types of housing
units smaller units. Available
for immediate shelter I'm
certain locality senses the
city of LA cannot you like
structures such as committee
cabins because of the currently
permitted they're not currently
for and it the state. Would
like you to help us we don't
know if that's a ministry to or
legislator the state of
California should develop an
expedited process to prove low
cost easily deployable
structures that can be
utilized. As emergency in
around housing
. And my name is
Marie Ramsey and I'm here on
behalf of the central city
association we are a membership
organization comprised of about
four hundred members focused on
downtown's vibrancy and
increasing investment in the
region. And I'll keep my
remarks brief because I know
it's been a long hearing- and a
lot of great stuff has been
said I agree with all the
previous speakers. I think just
real big picture we need a lot
more housing we haven't been
building and not. At housing
production is falling behind
over the last seventy years
I'll share some stats from the
city of LA- and I think to that
end of for this group- we
really need to consider
something like SB fifty that
would enable the construction
of housing statewide. I think
until we get to more units
everywhere we're going to be
facing this problem over and
over again and I also think we
need to figure out a way to get
private sector to build more
units that are affordable by
right. We are never going to
have enough subsidies do that
so we need to figure out a way
to involve people. And just
quickly to share some stats- in
the city of Los Angeles before
nineteen. Thirty died me bill
300-100-0400 fifty two units.
418-402-1950 nine. We but built
almost. Nothing. In nineteen
seventy nine without about four
hundred thousand units. From
nineteen eighty to nineteen
ninety nine we built about two
hundred and forty one thousand
units. From two thousand till
now we've built about a hundred
and thirty seven thousand
units. So our production has
sharply fallen. I'm here in
downtown we've seen a great
production of units but we're
still just scratching the
surface. So as state
legislators we thank you for
your attention to this matter
we appreciate your hard work in
your commitment- and we ask
that you embrace something like
SB fifty this next legislator.
Thank you. Thank you. I'm their
best on the executive director
of the historic core business
improvement district and I also
serve on the HHH- oversight
committee and- I'd echo what
Marie said- appreciate all the
comments on housing and the
fact that we need to build more
and faster and for less money
that was one of the things on
the committee that was very
disappointing to us is the high
cost per unit and we really
wanted to push the idea of
shared housing and other more
innovative ideas and just eight
you know we get get gets away
from you you don't have much
time to implement this and
that. And it takes to develop
these per is to long- so I have
a great many ideas about that
to discuss at another time and
I was asked mainly focus on-
mentally ill and addicted which
as a function of the bed we've
worked on with individuals on
the streets implemented I never
approach I'm sorry excessively
in some not- SB eighty two with
of them. I'm not can didn't
that are sky high and if you
have a medical emergency that
it can cripple you financially
and many financial reasons why
people end up in homelessness
but it feels like the stigma of
mental illness diction and- is
still preventing us from help
those who need it the most. I'm
in the eighteen sixty one the
hospital's of close down.
Kennedy in the rated the now
it's to the mental health. It
was a- temperature than you
know they were considered in
hospitable- the mentally ill
were then left to. Their own
communities- and the support
the local support just never
came- and by the time Reagan
took office over four hundred
thousand people. Had already
been released into their
communities from the state
hospitals- so if you research
now state after state- it. Has
two function and deal with
people who suffer from and also
knows yeah- which is that they
don't recognize their illness
and they don't speak voluntary
on going care. Op so what that
means really is ER's and
prisons are are defective care
for these folks and- that's
inappropriate in in humane- and
now people are being released
on. The streets- due to
propositions and other
legislation without the support
they were promised. So I'm not
gonna miss words of what we
have here now is just a saying
to a sanctioned system of
neglect. And we need to first
recognize that and then vowed
to change it- we need support
from our brother and sister
state this is not just a local
issue or a California issue
this is a national issue-
Medicaid needs to support. Care
for mental illness for larger
inpatient facilities- when we
pass legislation like prop
sixty three for once we need to
make a priority people
suffering from severe mental
illness- we need to create
longer term beds and not allow
people in crisis to be released
within a matter of hours. In a
vulnerable fledgling state- we
need to look at the late term
in Petra short act which was
mentioned earlier by-
supervisor mark Ridley Thomas-
we need to re evaluate how the
holds are being utilized are
they being utilized and do the
guidelines actually have
positive results for anyone
suffering from mental illness.
But the law was intended to end
in debt indefinite
inappropriate holds guarantee
public safety prevent
unnecessary expenditures and
protect persons with mental
health disorders from criminal
acts. I think anecdotally in
statistically we can tell that
that's not what that's not what
is happening- people are
cycling. In and out of the E.
R. on a regular basis- cycling
to the prison system we're
spending resources attempting
to turn law enforcement
personnel into mental health
care providers rather than
using doctors and nurses
already trained in the field.
Rather than providing places
for people to go that protects
them- and others- and we have a
brewing public safety and
public health crisis so I. I
just feel like that's a that's
an excellent place to start and
it says it's a subsector the
population that to me is- very
near and dear to me as I'm been
downtown working amongst it for
seventeen years and lived here
for over eight. Thank you
. One
want to try and going last but
there's a lot of things that
have already been set I'm
sorry. That's right. Yeah yeah
so- I'd obviously there's a lot
of really good ideas that were
discussed here today and- much
like assembly member Santiago
said this is just the first of
many discussions- we are family
at least from our point of
view. On the ground you know
and serving the community that
all of us are fighting for we
want to make sure that the
urgency the sense of urgency
that is being articulated
today- is kept up and- also
turned into velocity you know
we know that resources are here
we know that- money is here.
But we also want to make sure
that the dollar that we get
turned into a dollar twenty
five that the minute were
trying to save turns into two
minutes because that's really
kind of what we're living with
you know- now that in two
thousand sixteen a lot of these
measures. Passed one of the
things that you know I just
wanna take an opportunity to do
is to echo some of the things
that again on the ground that
were living with that we want
to make sure look really gets
at home as priority. You know
senator Mitchell. Clearly
outlined that you know things
AB and flow so a lot of the
things that I think that our
community keeps you know. What
keeps us about it is when this
runs out. Like let's just say
for example we get the majority
of the people off the street
and housing services provided.
How does the funding for the
next five ten fifteen years how
do we sustain that. You know so
while we take the chronically
homeless or the those that are
on the street and lift them up
into a house environment. What
are we doing to stop the
slippage of economic
homelessness or youthful
homelessness or things like
that so was worth reading those
two parallel tracks today
because we do have the sense of
urgency. Let's not forget that
we have the obligation
responsibility and the next
five ten fifteen years to make
sure that that's funded and
supported as well. So I to
federal level as long as
there's like awareness that's
given to that other
opportunities that we can
leverage states such as
Medicaid Medicare how. We know
that there's a lot of
individuals on the street that
are aging in place that they're
going to have a lot of
different needs and the next to
five five to ten years. Are
there senior living facilities
that we can convert some of the
homeless population that we
have today that opens up units
that we can continue to move
people in off the street. But
making sure that we look at it
kind of as a system as a
conduit to continue to solve.
Some of the law the law more
local or state you know- focus
solutions get. Everyone's
already thank you know assembly
member Thiago before AB eleven
ninety spent but developer at
its get row housing tract. That
is really going to help us
perpetuate facilitating hit
velocity of development. So it
gets people off measure H.
helps us provide service.
Master and then was a lot of
Xin earlier big act I can
workforce develop and how do we
allow people to perpetuate
itself state. It doesn't mean
they have like a large sum of
money to. Do it I feel like
they're contributing to self
success and giving back to the
community. One of the last- key
points that I think that you
know a will be at the
organization wanna make and
treat said at a very very well
earlier. Is they can move the
needle very quickly a lot
faster than we can so when we.
Facilitates sport and help the
community is that ours are on
the street once their house
they are faster at finding
solutions and finding the
people that still need to be
housing breaking down those
barriers and the last pieces of
the data all of us talk about
data you know and from our
organization from. Al all of
our you know counterparts is.
Angeles and California are
leading data providers we can
be- the solution that sometimes
we hear about like Houston is
huge we know that there's a lot
of air time on that but Los
Angeles and San Francisco in
Sacramento we have the data
we've solve problems. We can do
influences kinda nationwide as
well so- with that again thank
you very much for this
opportunity and allowing me to
close this out. Thank you very
much all panel
. There's just so
many good people we need to
include the mall but- I really
appreciate that I'm gonna open
up to. A to the committee
members of those any questions
this Hertzberg. This store make
a statement that so much a
question. You know recently
under the leadership of
assembly member- com all their
dove. She did a great job in
bringing us together is in LA
county delegation. I think it's
something like forty members of
the legislature between both
the assembly and the Senate
representing LA county. And I
gotta tell you it's important
message to go forth to all of
us. I think the thing that came
out of that is that we all
agreed before this but I was
before this polar wasn't it was
it was influenced by that or
not I would suggest it was
before that. Which we're going
to make this a priority we're
going to develop a strategic
plan and we've already of the
monks ourselves talked about a
number of the issues that are
represented here today. But to
really be a dynamic force from
LA county it's hard to pull us
all together from all different
corners of the county people in
one but every the county and
the other is a county don't we
know each other well we have a
good. And this is a priority
and you're gonna see I think
and I think this this hearing
today. Are the German was
there. Was was is part of that
effort and so I I'm really
excited about that I'm excited
about the interest among all of
us and the willingness for all
of us to work together to take
a strategic approach. For
deliverables for us Senate
forty members of the
legislature I think we have
some ability particularly with
the number of us who are on
their to actually have some
important immediate impact.
Please I'm trying to get. That
same out county caucus
conveniently the meeting. Over
here now- we also heard from
doctor sharing and heard the
issue about the board and care
and so is something we're
definitely gonna pay attention
to I wish it was it was.
Mathematically a simple as you
suggested the bad that are
going to use and it's just not-
so forgive me for. Shaking my
head which distracted you- but
but we are clear about the
challenge- and as I said
earlier you know the notion of
government and we create these
funding silos you know the fact
that eighteen HHX dollars can
be used to fund board care
beds. Was perhaps short sighted
and so yeah. They can you can
you confirm the services but
not the bad or the reverse.
Eighty so if you fund the bed.
Did not no place like home
actually. ATK. There are
several nay taking projects
that are you know the but
they're not. And talk about the
things that they actually are
everything. Because it funds
the bad enough to service am I
saying that right it's funds
the if funds the service. HHH
is only half right. Ease of
use. That term. Right so what
funds the bed death but not the
services that need to go along
in a board and care for
funding. For supporting that
person. That's right. Yeah
right. No place like home. I
got it I got it so the point is
valid that we create these
funding streams that are so
silence so narrow that we don't
have the flexibility big to be
creative so we're going to look
at- the role we have played in
under cutting the boarding care
system in a very meaningful
way- the doctor here brought
that to our attention. I times
is covered in our colleague
assembly member bloom actually
had a bill- but but we at the
caucus are going to put our
shoulder to the grindstone and
prioritize the board care issue.
I think the shared housing
piece is another example of-
you know how can we creatively
come up with ways to X. to
extend the reach. In impact of
the dollar. And so- we will
continue to do that- some of us
have tour doubles
municipalities aye I think he's
gone- I went to Utah that's why
California is now a- housing
first date we went to Utah saw
that came back introduced the
bill. I went to Utah and that's
why California now has a-
homeless coordinating council
I'm and so we've been to those
places we look at the models-
and we all have to acknowledge
that you know California eight
Utah or Arizona- we have-
unique- characteristics- and
unique challenges and unique
opportunities. And so we're
looking at those models and
bringing to bear what is
appropriate let's helpful
that's not new we've done that
for a number of years. And will
continue to do so- I think what
is new. For us what I did see
in you thought and didn't
experience. The cal. Our
policy. What do you top five
years ago. Is now we are in a
place where every level of
government sense federal
government but death while
actions matter- are on the same
page. When the state took the
vote to eliminate redevelopment.
This they walked away. And an
expected municipalities to
figure it out. The state walked
away when the state in the
early two thousands cut cal
work grant deeply- and so every
level of government has to bear
some responsibility but the
fact that we are now on the
same page when you can see the
example an H. HHH and heat
alphabet soup where we are
putting our collective
resources and energy and bright
thinking and commitment to
sustained investment over time
that creates a new space in a
way in which I think we are
operating as government
California and that's the good
news that I take away- from the
action that we take in. Thank
you very much for inviting
members of the Senate dissipate
this hearing I was sharing with
my colleagues. My sitting pro
TM when she never first these
to the assembly chair of the
select committee. And had a
hearing very similar to today
S. Skid Row we start the
morning we walked to Skid Row.
Then we came in and had a
hearing. I wish I could but ten
years the data has improved it
at that has that much. What
struck me then is consistent
today when we look at quite
frankly the complexion of those
who need the services and the
complexion of those to provide
the services it's still Chiu
strikingly different I'm not
sure why that is- vertically
when you hear a message from to
reset. Where people talk about
want to know that they're
talking to someone who's had a
sure there lived experiences so
I think we also have a lot of
work to do. To make sure that
we are. Listening hearing
scheme and being compassionate
and our policy. And that would
developing housing and policy
responses that are meaningful
and relevant to the people who
need the services. Thank you
for the invitation today and
for all of you for
participating. Since the first
of all let me say thank you
very much- echo what my
colleagues on the Senate has
already raised- I would not be
redundant but I will say I
think the panel was very robust
I appreciate- each of you have
certainly given me a greater
insight- I've tried to take a
very copious notes- around
paper nice I use in my bones I
wasn't texting anywhere
disrespecting. But but I've
certainly believe that I have
some policy ideals that will-
one is very timely because
we're on recess we go back in
January Chiang were six. And we
have an opportunity to go back
and take what you have shared
and create some public policy
but I think it would help move
the needle and also look at
tangible- measurable- changes
taking place around
homelessness here- and-
California and so I want to
thank. Everyone and I want to
apologize for eating now- what
at opportunity to hear the
public- I'm hearing. Testimony
but I'll look at that. And I
will suggest the chairman if-
at the staff in other will
provide. A some notes that you
may have shared and share those
knows with the entire our
offices. Here maybe follow ups
thank you much. If you're. The
card is already plotting and
planning. But but look we want
to thank everybody who's you're
not gonna go long winded and
speech here but but what I do
want to say what's unique about
it in this was part of the
conversations that we've had
over the years in terms of
prioritizing- homelessness.
Homelessness issue- was to
create select committee for LA
county that was specific but
what what was also unique about
it I think is that the fact
that. You have most of the
other a good portion Daly
members were active on the
issue here and then- and all
all I go with my colleagues of
said we invited the Senate as
well so we just don't only have
support on the assembly side
from a few people but we- also
have. The support on on the
side and not your- and people
who carry weight as well- the
budget chair on the Senate side
and the Majority Leader on the
Senate side- oddity Mister
draws of who. Covers the ski
area well we tried to buy the
way it will have some sort of.
Tangible gains. Budget just.
When it in the book. The
people's together not a plan
out over the next year. From
the how big substantive change.
Or at least make some serious
Denson and achieving- to house
people. Now I do wanna take of
the moment- the go to hope-
public comments. And we've
asked the public comments could
be held to one minute. If
that's okay no one thank you.
Again for that if I'm speeding
through its just because we
went over by about a half hour
sub also learned. A little bit
about that as well so banks. If
we start with public comments
were the Mike public comment
because I could see that it I
know that we had a represents a
canister white who was invited
to participate but- if we could
have you go first if you if
you're okay with that. You
have. A baby. Okay that's fine.
Let's get that for the
remainder of the people we're
gonna cut off at one minute
during public comments and I
just feel really fast. Nine
nine I appreciate that I just.
Thank you. One is I will be
following up with all the
presenters and so forth on next
steps as well thank you so
really quickly my name is white
with the Los Angeles community
action network based here in
Skid Row right down the street
the founder of LA can twenty
five years ago and so just a
couple of things really quickly
losses twenty nineteen dated
documented that 71% of houses
people are households as a
result of housing affordability
housing availability and
poverty only twenty nine
percent. Reported the house
lives as a result of mental.
The music diagnoses. Portent at
will **** issue that we're not
target in the issue in the
inverse oftentimes with
thinking. It's as a result of
mental illness and substance
abuse where it's very clearly
about housing. This points to
structural and institutional
racism in a broken system
safety net of care the points
organized abandonment with
roots in de industrialization.
The drug wars a cretin cling
climb bill and related
expansions of prisons targeting
black and brown. People welfare
reform and the decimation of
the safety net as you spoke of
earlier- honorable I'm Mitchell
this is not a by product of bad
decisions by individuals. This
is a systematic attack on
surplus workers and communities
of color that no longer had
value senator Dorado was
absolutely correct. When she
said that we must take into
account the seven hundred.
Twenty one thousand families
each one point five million
people who are currently. Being
hopeless you were irate. Out
of. This thing is. Not a static
dominant right three things we
must tackle run play rents per
building unit cost of six
hundred thousand plus 45% of
those costs going to the
building. 40% going toward soft
costs and 11% covering the lan
must not happen city owned
property both weapon buildings
must be used to deal with the
crisis. The city of Los Angeles
own seven thousand parcels not
four hundred twenty eight arm
of both land and structures we
need to go back and harking
back to the times of mayor Tom
Bradley when he opened. City
hall to house house was people
we need to make sure we have.
Government land lastly we must
stop all instead of
criminalization of house was
people instead provide public
health infrastructure for and
sheltered. Houses people
additionally municipalities
must stop pursuing the
overturning a federal court
just. Like Martin forces boys.
Are in order simply read
communities of those people. We
the land need city owned land
we need to reduce the cost of
building and we need to get our
office today. And we're not be
eight to speak out rate. Thank
you so much. Mister white. City
your reference that. Hi so
that's and that's basically it
that's not big. Well that's the
at entire available you land
and buildings that the city of
Los Angeles owns today that
came out of a report that was
released two months ago from
Ron CalPERS so it's seven
thousand parcels of both raw
land and building I would say
on the properties with
buildings on them in Los
Angeles we have the adaptive
reuse ordinance we need to put
the adaptive reuse. Ordinance
in fact we all know that
building cost. But for
buildings that have been long
abandoned there's no profit
there so we need to return
those to people for one dollar
per month. Yeah right and the
rest of the comments we're
going to keep the one minute-
that was a special. Reason for
that thank you. We have as a
meaning. A good afternoon that
you guys so much for your time
my name's Alex contrast I'm
with the housing coalition-
statewide nonprofit called
California yes in my backyard
and one thing that I've
frequently come across is that
local cities I live within the
county but in the city of
Downey are often resistant to
these measures and issues and
solutions that we are trying to
come up with two day. And one
way that you guys can make it
more easier is the advocating
through state what policy that
out Ste essentially forces
cities to take action since
they're not held accountable
where the can do that is
through SB fifty of more homes
act currently right now we are
faced housing shortage and most
people that I work with are on
the verge of becoming homeless
because they're having the
right burdened. Dust people to
talk to days day people who
cannot afford to live a were
they are currently where they
work- and they're forced into
longer commutes which hurts our
environment- so essentially if
we can build homes more homes
where. The jobs are at that
would. Help tax this is. There
is some time. Course every was
government my name is Corey
Patterson I am a current
resident Skinner housing trust
graciously. Things that
reflected today in my mind are
the complexion of this is issue
a shocking. Urgent urgent
urgent. Money is power but I
will add action is honor.
Adaptive assistance is needed
as least spoke about I would
love to graduate into a section
eight housing with that company.
I am in. A great assisted
living program I'm not an
addict I have an assisted dog
David gap did to comedy me I'm
gracious and gracious for
everybody in this room and this
time. Thank you very much. Any
additional comments yes please
yeah. In all these things all
the
. My name is Colleen Katie
and I've been previously been a
resident here at the mine cart
fifteen years ago- and I've
been on my own for those
fifteen years and right now I'm
dealing with my bill is being.
Sold and the guy is already
knocking on doors trying to
give a get us to get cash for
keys and we have other issues
but my big big issue for you
guys because you're state level
and the city doesn't have
anything to do with it. How are
you guys going to or what can
you do about the- Ellis act
because it's been used an abuse
in ways that it wasn't right
there virtually but intended to.
Thank you next. Hi some my
background with homelessness is
that my parents were homeless-
when I was two weeks old and it
was a family of four children
and so all throughout my life
AB try to understand how did
they get homeless because they
were brilliant people and so I
noticed that it can happen to
anyone and I is could possibly
happen to me very soon- the
thing that I currently live
that is- housing trust building
but I was in there- experiment
that they started in two
thousand twelve with a house
artist. The newspaper actually
me about that experience and
you know it could rate and
we'll see what happens seven
years later I'm still there but
now they are- they just raised
our rents and we believe
there's about eight units in
that building that has not been
house for years now. On top of
that I'm their issues that are
happening at you can see how
people can back into homeless
very quickly and that better.
Learn I mean. So what. Ten and
we need are also if we can stop
the things that are happening
right now that is one of the
most important things that we
can do. Because yes you're
fine. No no definitely but I'm
just saying that we don't have
help I need help I don't know
who to go to I just met Lee so
I hopefully that'll I help
something out there but I do
doctor office in the back and
then we'll could have they're
entitled your office. As well.
Thanks I would like to. Thank
you. Francis yes mean Moti wala
a candidate for Congress in CA
thirty four. And I a for
someone to say thank you so
much for all the work that
you're doing and having this
meeting- couple things I want
to draw attention to. One is at
the federal level is great to
hear some conversation
suggesting things that they can
do. I wanted to point out the
people's action how Aaron T. at
something that as you all-
talked your colleagues above
you and in the federal level a
something encourage our
representatives and senators to
be. Looking into in sporting-
because I do believe that at
the federal level we have a lot
to cheap to support the work
that you're doing. A second I
just want to bring up the- over
the next decade we have.
Challenges on climate change in
addressing not. And this crisis
and we've got a potential
Olympics coming to Los Angeles.
And I just want to make sure
that. That our leaders are
looking at- the potential costs
and impacts of the Olympics on
our- poor up. On the poor and
just to be. So many just please
pay attention to the a large
cost per sister short period of
time the benefits just a small
group of people and can have a
massive impact on everyone else
thank you. Thank you for your
time. I think that can.
Comments so thank you for your
time and we'll call it a day
thank you. Thank you